[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
Friday Friday Friday Friday
you need a big ass chicken [__]
remember when he was like I'm gonna have
evidence that's gonna exonerate me
Mike lindell's gonna show it to the
world in Springfield Missouri this week
and then I'm gonna come out and I'm
gonna I'm gonna act like it's the
evidence that's gonna exonerate me and
then he's like oh yeah there there is no
evidence oh yeah I forgot
even my Glendale said it at the stupid
uh floppapalooza
in Springfield Missouri he's like uh
this isn't about evidence because we
don't really have any
a lot of people are asking me like
what's gonna happen when he does this
press conference on Monday when he shows
the the evidence and I was like look
it's more white wet fart in a white
thong moment
and we're not we're not even gonna get a
toot here that's the shitty part I
wanted him to do the press conference to
be quite honest with you I told you that
I hope I want him to do a press
conference every day have you seen this
[__] doreen's lunatics newest video
on Jack Smith and just the absolute
deranged word salad
oh my I'm going to show it to you today
it's worth it trust me trust me it's
worth it
he's also not going to go to the debates
which I said he wouldn't go to the baits
either he's not going to debate Chris
Christie he's not gonna do it
like he'll go he would go if Chris
Christie wasn't going he would go to go
beat the [__] out of DeSantis
and finally uh throw the last shovel of
dirt on his political career does
xanthus's political career
but he's not going to do that because
Chris Christie's going to be there
and Chris Christie would make a [__]
fool out of him
in front of the entire world so Donald
Trump isn't going to risk that no
[__] way would Donald Trump race
Chris Christie absolutely ripping him to
shreds in front of the American people
and providing video for us to [__]
make fun of him for months
no [__] I mean he's dumb but he ain't
that [__] stupid is he
maybe but he ain't gonna go he ain't
gonna go because he's a coward he's a
chicken [__] he's a yellow belly little
[__] is what he is
[__] ass [__] to be exact
so he's not gonna go debate Chris
Christie he's not gonna do it
but you know if you want to have the the
sensation of well
it'll be bad for Trump because someone
will emerge out of the debates no they
won't
listen the only person that really has a
chance here
of putting a dent in any of his
delegates is Chris Christie and only in
New Hampshire
think about that for a second right
think about this Rhonda Santos's
strategy is Iowa that's clear
he's failing badly
like not only is Donald Trump going to
win Iowa but he's going to absolutely
make a fool out of DeSantis if DeSantis
decides to stay in this race honestly
Hey Ron
Ron I don't know I don't know who your
new um manager is or who your new
political advisors are but you might
want to get him on the phone with me
because my advice to them would be for
you to drop out now just drop out now
and say what you're gonna do is go turn
Florida into 1930s Germany go do that
and then try that because maybe you'll
Advance your political career by proving
to the world that you're you know the
Florida fascist
because honestly you're destroying any
chance you have of being any kind near
any kind of political office uh for the
rest of your life I don't know Ron
listen you need to go look up who Scott
Walker was maybe you could call the guy
maybe you could call Scott maybe that's
a good idea call Scott get Scott on the
phone and see if you can determine why
you're the next Scott Walker and if you
don't know who Scott Walker is Ron
that's the point like that's the point
meatball
is that
you're not gonna make it man
now Chris Christie he's got he oh man
he's got a shot in New Hampshire I mean
if you want to consider maybe maybe
he'll get 20 25 of the primary vote
which is not even close
and if Trump takes Iowa and New
Hampshire back to back
that's that's it [__] there's
no one else gonna emerge he's it
why why do you think
he continues to say and what's hit lets
his supporters believe that he's still
the president you know why that is right
because incumbency carries a huge huge
huge advantage
so his
um delusional fictional incumbency for
some of his supporters
is carrying huge advantage and that's
it's how Cults work
I I don't know I don't know how else to
say it said it a million times I'm
probably gonna say it a million more
until he's the nominee it's how Colts
work and you know what's funny is the
the mainstream media is starting to come
around to this I've been saying this for
months and months and months but the
mainstream media is finally going whoa
DeSantis is not going to beat him
Chris Christie is not going to beat him
in New Hampshire and if he wins Iowa and
New Hampshire
well that's that's it that's the ball
game
oh man you know sometimes people get mad
at me for um
for knocking on the media on how bad
they are at this but they're horrible
the political analysts are horrible
sometimes a legal analyst or they're
just [__] horrible it's bad it's bad
and the main reason why it's bad is
because they think their job is to make
you feel good
like that that's what they think their
job is they're like you know we need to
tell our audience what they want to hear
so let's get a guest on to say a bunch
of [__] that's not even [__]
close to the truth and let's get them on
and let's uh let's let's uh let's make
them feel good get the [__] out of here
with that nonsense that is not that is
not how you make people motivated to be
engaged in their democracy
it is not
being engaged in your democracy means
you know you're going to have a little
bit of passion about it
you got a little fire about it
and having someone tell you oh yeah he's
definitely definitely gonna go to trial
wink I've heard this time and time again
I've had people type out the comment
Tony he's got seven trials scheduled
next year I'm like yeah think about that
think about it think about this for a
second and this comes on the heels of
Donald Trump the news yesterday of
Donald Trump and his legal team asking
for a trial in April
of 2026. now I know where this number
comes from a lot of people are
postulating it several different things
but here's gonna be their [__]
argument
okay now they have a decent argument
with how much Discovery there is there
was a lot of criming happen there was a
lot of crime that happened
uh for the January 6th Insurrection
before and after oh a lot of crime there
was a shitload of crime so there's like
gazillions of documents documenting
their crime
so the attorneys they have they actually
have justification that they have to go
through this discovery because he is
entitled to a defense whether you like
it or not that's how our system works
he's entitled to defense and they're
going to defend him and they get to look
at this discovery so no judge in their
right mind is going to set a January a
January [__] trial date when you just
handed over like two million documents
okay listen I know I know you want it to
go fast I I understand this but be
realistic here be realistic use your
brain don't don't use your emotions when
you're thinking about these things right
not when you're talking about the trial
we want worst case scenario here right
we want to go off a worst case scenario
not best case best case scenario
[__] would already be locked
away in a prison somewhere in a basement
for the rest of his [__] life that
would be best case scenario well we're
not even close to best case scenario at
this point so let's just focus on worst
case scenario worst case scenario is we
gotta vote this [__] off the
planet again
okay that's worst case scenario we're
his [__] jury that's the worst case
that's why I keep saying it I don't know
if he'll go to I don't think he will but
I don't know for sure if he's going to
go to trial or not before the election
but I'm trying to prep the people out
there the American people that don't
count on it there's no [__] guarantee
stop making it like someone else's Gonna
Save Your Ass
you've got the ability to go dunk on
this [__] we got we got plenty
of time and plenty of ability and plenty
of ways to do it get out there and get
this [__] vote going and beat him on
the battleground of The Ballot Box
that will keep him out of our [__]
government
might not keep them out of our Lives
because the [__] idiot won't shut the
hell up but that's that's a whole nother
[__] ball of Wax
but his team asked for a um a trial in
the in the uh in the Insurrection case
the election interference case in
Washington DC that Jack Smith has
indicted him I used the grand jury to
indict him on
now I know where they're getting this
number right think about this for a
second so they keep saying what took two
and a half years it took two and a half
years it took two and a half years it
took two and a half years okay you got
it you gotta get the mindset of being
stupid to try to sell them smart right
think about this they're trying to sound
smart but they're really [__] dumb
so what they're going to try to say is
well it took Jack Smith two and a half
years to indict me so it should take two
and a half years for us to go through
the evidence that we created because of
our criminal [__] Enterprise
to go to trial which is unrealistic as
well it's unrealistic to think that a
defense needs the exact amount of time
that the [__] prosecutors need to
investigate a crime where they had to
uncover and do testimony and all this
[__]
but there is going to be stalling there
is going to be big delays and the one
reason why is because there was so much
criming
there was so much [__] crime again
the first cachet of documents of
discovery that Donald Trump's legal team
has has received is like one and a half
million pages
that's a lot of crime I don't know I
don't know I don't know if you're
counting
that's a lot of [__] crime
so it's going to take a bit for them to
uh I don't know go through it and defend
the undefensible really not speaking
defending the undefensible uh cheese
burrow
one of his aides now cheese bro
apparently he said he's one of the the
main architects of the coup plot the
Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
the guy was walking around the capitol
on January 6 with none other than Alex
Jones Alex Jones
I wonder if he was getting rid of them
demons in the capital I don't know
maybe
um I find it kind of funny though that
um
Alex Jones doesn't appear in the
indictments
he didn't appear in the indictments for
The Oath Keepers the proud boys we
talked about Roger Stone yesterday and
he's not indicted yet
and Alex Jones and and uh
um Roger Stone are kind of you know Cut
From the Same Cloth
I wonder I wonder hey hey hey Grandpa
um I know you're a Bedminster
I wonder I wonder if you know this I
wonder if you know that Alex Jones and
Roger Stone has turned evidence on you
do you know that
I don't know that I'm not really sure of
it but
suspicious
it seems like they even turned evidence
on the Proud boys and The Oath Keepers
if you want to know the [__] honest
truth we've had we'd have we've had
Dakota Adams on here before Stuart
Rhodes's son a strange son and and his
estranged ex-wife now uh Tasha Adams
and uh I asked them specifically and
they told me that Stuart Rhodes used to
sleep
I'm not [__] you this is this is
what was told to me Stewart Rhodes used
to sleep on Alex Jones's couch
when he was Couchsurfing when he was
looking for a blaze to stay he would go
stay with Alex Jones
I don't know it seems it seems Alex
Jones and Stuart Rhodes know each other
really well it seems Roger Stone knows
the proud boys and The Oath Keepers very
well
I mean cheese burrow cheeseborough was
all up in Alex Jones's ass on January
6th
he was a main architect of the fake
State elector scheme
I you know I I'm not trying to spend
conspiracy theories or put on a tenfold
hat it just seems [__] weird doesn't
it
that Alex Jones and Roger Stone is
somehow abated Federal investigations
and federal indictments and even State
indictments in these cases
doesn't it seem weird
I mean Oath Keepers Oath Keepers Stuart
Rhodes was sentenced to what 21 years or
18 years I forget here's a couple
decades apparently uh the prosecutors
are asking for 30 years are over 30
years for Enrique tario
the proud boys leader
who wasn't even at
the capitol on January 6. think about
that his sedition was so steep right
that the [__] wasn't even at the
Capitol on January 6 and he's the
prosecutors are asking for 30 years
after he is found guilty
think about that
think about that for a second
Roger Stone and Alex Jones
cheeseborough was with Alex Jones right
[__] the oath probboys were protecting
uh Roger Stone and then they flipped and
Let The Oath Keepers give him protection
Roger Stone has a direct phone line
direct phone line to Donald Trump
think about it just [__] think about
it for a second why in the [__]
if cheese burrow
and that's his name cheese Barrel
if cheeseburger
was at the Capitol with Alex Jones on
January 6 and he's the main architect of
the Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
his idea was oh yeah Mike Pence can just
yeah yeah [__] he can just name whatever
electors he wants and these states oh
yeah just anybody can be electors
especially the ones that are like we
want Trump even though he didn't win we
want Trump and it's not legal and it's
fraud we want Trump
think about it think about the webbing
you know I I'd love to put up you know
red string on a white board and [__]
but you really don't have to with this
there's not a lot of there's not a web
that you have to really think about much
it's like okay Roger Stone is direct
contact Donald Trump best friends best
buddies they love each other and I'm not
sure if uh Roger Stone has a tattoo of
Trump's face on him yet but he has one
at Nixon
um and then Alex Jones Alex Jones is
best buddies with The Oath Keepers and
the proud boys knows him personally
the founder of The Oath Keepers who was
who was
indicted charms convicted and sentenced
to two decades for seditious conspiracy
used to sleep on his couch
Roger Stone's been on Alex Jones Show
many times Donald Trump's been on shows
many times proud boys Oath Keepers
these [__] know each other
intimately maybe even more intimately
than what we want to know
I don't know
that's probably the that's probably the
the most outlandish conspiracy theory
that I've been talking about the last
five minutes
it is not it is not outlandish to think
that Roger Stone and Alex Jones has
flipped and turned State evidence
against Donald Trump Against The Oath
Keepers against the proud boys it is not
that is not out of the realm of
possibility it certainly is not because
we haven't seen their names appear on
any indictments
and we and we know that we know Trump is
chicken [__]
you gotta know that Alex Jones and Roger
stones are full on chicken [__] what do
you think the tough guy attitude is from
them
Roger Stone you know in in [__]
testimony and depositions just grit in
his teeth grinding his teeth
Alex Jones going to the Capitol telling
him it's going to be a war and all kinds
of crazy [__] and it's going to be their
Waterloo and you remember that Alex
Jones tonight on January 5th their rally
the night before he was telling him it's
gonna be the Waterloo and all this [__]
he was trying to rah-rah the [__]
violent mob up the the night before
I wonder I wonder if cheese bro
I wonder if he I I don't maybe he was
communicating with Alex Jones who knows
who knows
I don't know maybe I got my tin foil hat
on
but it seems it seems as if these things
have to do with each other
they really do and I I know we're two
and a half years away from January 6.
like it feels like ah you know it's old
news and this and that but honestly
um I don't care when Donald Trump goes
to trial for this I really don't give a
[__] this DC trial I don't care if it's
next year the year after [__] if if
chuckon's like yeah
that sounds about right April of 2026.
she's not gonna say that by the way
check is not gonna is not gonna set this
trial
for the year 2026 no [__] way you you
people right look listen she's gonna say
okay so you're telling me that you need
six years
to know what crime you did or didn't do
get the [__] out of here with this
nonsense she's not gonna do that just
like she's not gonna set a trial for
January she's not gonna do it
I I will be very surprised if she sets
anything anything sooner than the summer
of next year I'll be really surprised
I'll be really surprised
but she's not she's not going to give
Jack Smith what he wants either I I hope
you're prepared for that
I hope you're prepared to be a little
pissed off at judge chutkin
I hope you're prepared yourself that her
decision isn't going to be exactly what
you want
and you need to probably prepare
yourself because I know the media isn't
Preparing People very very well for this
for the reality of it they're like oh
yeah then we're going to get exactly
what we want this guy's gonna be in an
orange jumpsuit and blah blah blah get
the [__] out of here
no he's not
listen the guy is kept attacking people
on social media and ain't [__] been none
about it
what's been done what what they do to
him huh
tell me
you give me proof you give me proof that
this guy isn't [__] in a second tier
of justice and I'll I'll I'll I'll give
you something but until then I got all
the proof I need
they're giving him all kinds of [__]
rope to hang himself here
all kinds of it and boy is he doing it
oh my God the more he talks listen this
guy real dude really thinks that he's
gonna be able to talk his way out of it
I'm in love with that idea I'm in love
with Donald Trump believing that he's
gonna talk his way out of these
indictments
it gets me excited to be quite honest
with you
I'm telling you it's it's gonna be wild
[__] next year
when they're in the heat of a primary
and they're trying to juxtaposition to
make sure that he doesn't go to trial
and that's the other thing you know I
get this from a lot of people they're
like oh man oh man oh man
oh he's got so many trials next year I'm
like you know that that doesn't that
doesn't bode well for for like the
trials that are not set yet
because no judge is gonna step on
another courtroom and another judge
right they're not going to do that
they're not gonna have this guy in 15
criminal trials all at once
a judge is not going to want that to
happen a judge wants to focus on their
trial in their courtroom at that time
they don't want any delays they don't
want any outside [__] coming in and
[__] with them they don't want any
outside court cases coming in and
[__] with their trial the judge is
not going to want to do that the judge
has to manage the [__] courtroom in
the trial
that's their [__] job
they want to make sure that that is
under control in an order
see you you don't you don't want them
stepping on each other really frankly
honestly and they're not they're not
going to
so
people are saying that the Discord link
is expired Discord is is getting crazy
over there you guys are over there on
Discord like crazy if you guys love the
chat
here on um
on on the YouTube channel you definitely
are going to want to um
you're definitely going to want to get
over to Discord let me give you the
correct I think we got the correct one
here now let me give you the correct uh
Discord link one that can get you there
an invite link uh let me put it in the
the chat here
on YouTube
you guys are you guys
man I tell you what
I say best audience in the world here's
why you guys are highly engaged and not
just like because you like the show
because you got a community building and
the community is building over on
Discord which is really great to see
because everyone can go over there what
the hell
why Why didn't it post what the okay
okay that's not that's not that's not
what I wanted
um here here it is I'm gonna try to post
in the YouTube chat again see if it goes
in it's saying it won't let me do it I
don't know
there it goes there's the Discord Link
in the YouTube chat if you want and it's
in the description down below so if you
guys want to go to Discord and do that
also if you want to do a venmo chat
venmo chat me there was several
yesterday I think I got to them all
yesterday now but if you want to send a
venmo chat just uh you'll find me at the
Tony Michaels on venmo chat or or you
can go to the link down below uh in in
the um
in the description below or you can go
to the Tony michaels.com let's see Tony
michaels.com
you can find the uh you can find the the
venmo chat link there at the Tony
michaels.com I'll put it up on the
screen
on the screen
it also follow us on Twitch it's free to
follow us on Twitch and really if you
have your um Amazon Prime account linked
to your Twitch account for the show go
to twitch.tv Tony Michaels and
re-subscribe and we've had several
people re-subscribe the last few days uh
to the Tony Michaels Channel with their
Amazon Prime account here's what happens
if you've got a Prime account you can
link it to your Twitch account you get
one free subscription uh with Amazon
gaming it doesn't cost you a single
nickel the directions are also at the
Tony michaels.com everything's at
thetonymichaels.com all that stuff is at
D Tony michaels.com if you want to find
it it's there today's episode is there
uh the the patreon link if you want to
join in on patreon patreon.com Michaels
we did a 10 minute tip yesterday on an
attack and pivot guide you should go
check that out on the YouTube channel
make sure to subscribe to the YouTube
channel you're not going to want to miss
a single thing turn on the notifications
hit the like button the reason why you
want to turn on the notifications is
because when we do it a round table of
democracy I post it live the next
morning so you can see it free you don't
have to you don't have to be a patreon
to see it uh yeah you if you want to
participate in the 10 minute tips and
the workshops for Roundtable democracy
go to
patreon.commichaels and you can do that
there also follow us on Facebook because
you can watch us live there every day at
the Tony Michaels
we're trying to just get everything
everywhere at once right you can also
download each episode on Apple Spotify
and Google which you should you should
download the audio version every day it
helps out the show gets us in the
rankings
keeps keeps us going here at the Tony
michaels.com
um you know we're gonna do bonehead of
the week today and it's Friday but I
want to show you this uh this crazy rant
that grandpa had
uh yesterday so so let's go to a break
when we come back we'll go we'll go to
some videotape we'll see if we can get
Gabe Sanchez on the air to do bonehead
of the week don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
wait was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam jams skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again years
bomb
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[__] them [__] em [__] em [__] em [__]
em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show Friday you know
what that means
bonehead of the week bonehead of the
week
bonehead of the week
now Bonet is one of my favorite segments
that we have here on the Tony Michaels
podcast
um and we've been doing it for a long
time I don't know if for new audience
members out there bonehead used to be a
weekend show
it was like a show in and of itself
that uh Gabe Gabe Sanchez is the one
who's like hey we need to do something
on the weekend because that's when we
were just doing one show a week we were
literally just doing one show on
Wednesdays it was a two-hour show on
Wednesdays he's like we need to do
something on the weekend
it's like okay well what are we gonna do
he's like well let's do something where
the audience is engaged
he's like you say bonehead a lot you say
bonehead a lot so let's do something
around bonehead I said we do bone end of
the week
and then we came up with the idea of you
guys voting for bonehead of the week
and you loved it and we did it on the
weekend for a long time it's like a 30
minute to an hour thing uh for like
I don't know a couple months
and then when we went to every single
weekday so we went from Wednesday show
uh two hours then we went to every
single weekday Monday through Friday we
did two hours every single day
we put bonehead of the week as the last
segment of the week to like finish off
the week
right like that's the exclamation point
on the week is the bone head of the week
where you vote you decide who is the
bonehead of the week
and we break it down for you
and there's been additions to it there's
been changes to it
we've aired at other places several
times
uh but bone of the week has always been
my favorite and the reason why is
because you guys get to vote
and we we just we go along with whatever
your vote is we don't rig the election
we don't rig it we don't change the
voting machines we don't try to suppress
your Vote or anything like that but I
have to admit yesterday when I posted on
YouTube I was at a concert last night
when I was posting it and so I was at a
concert last night and I was texting
Gabe and uh I said just post it and then
I'll put it on YouTube and I put it on
YouTube and when I copy and pasted to
put it on YouTube I didn't get the full
question up there and did anyone notice
that I didn't get the full question and
I really didn't even notice it till this
morning to be quite honest with you
again it was really loud the music was
hopping it was 90s hip-hop music it was
a great band it was a great time it's a
great concert last night
um that may be why I'm a little
maybe on why I'm a little tame this
morning some people are saying oh that
was a short rant why was it so short
well I mean just trying to have fun it's
Friday you know we're laid back here
it's getting to be the weekend or you
guys gonna have a good weekend what are
you what are you doing for the weekend
we're getting close to the end of the
summer here we're getting close to
everyone going back to school uh having
lots of lots of things to do other than
Recreation you know you can't kids games
and take them here and go there and get
school and the meeting here and this
meeting there
so what are you guys doing uh for the
weekend that's what I want to know what
are you doing for the weekends put it in
the chat what you're what you're doing
for the weekend
anyway let's have some fun let's let's
um let's go ahead and do ask me anything
if you guys got some uh venmo chants if
you want to get those highlighted uh
send me a venmo chat you can go to again
you can go to venmo just go to the Tony
Michaels on venmo or you can hit the
link down below
in the uh you hit the link Down Below in
the description
or I'll just put the link right here in
the chat for you that way if you wanna
if you want to
if you want to send a venmo chat you can
I'll bring it up on the screen but let's
do ask me anything see if you guys we
haven't done this in a while if you guys
got a a question we'll shoot the [__]
here I guess we call it shoot the [__]
on the show we can't ask me anything on
patreon so go ahead and give me give me
a
give me a question if you got a question
tell me what you're gonna do this
weekend
um rocket Rod said what 90s hip-hop band
it's a local band here in Missouri it's
a local Bland band they're called dope
ass sneakers it's pretty [__] good
and I ain't gonna lie
they were damn good they were damn good
it's called dope ass sneakers
again they're local band here in in
Central Missouri we went we went and
seen them last night it was a great it
was a great show it's a great show
so uh so if you do if you go to uh shoot
the [__] uh if you guys want a venmo
chat you can venmo chat me but if you
want to if you want you can ask a
question here in the chat
um Larry Harris says Tony who is your
favorite comedian my favorite comedian
of all time has to be the one the only
the goat the greatest of all time George
Carlin uh a close very very very close
second
is Richard Pryor and even closer to that
is probably Eddie Murphy
delirious and raw were [__] amazing
some of the best uh
comedy specials of all time before
comedy specials were comedy specials and
Richard Pryor had a great had great
great
uh comedy special as well but George
Carlin is the goat
um it's kind of where I get my attitude
if you if you want to know the honest
truth when I was uh when I was coming of
age as they say when you're a teenager I
you know I would watch a lot of
political stuff
um I was in the politics when I was like
14 or 15 years old I'd stay up each
night doing my homework in my room and
I'd ride a little black and white TV
that I bought like at a garage sale it's
like a little bit he didn't have the
knobs on it and [__] you know I had the
bunny ears hooked up I only got like one
channel and the one channel I did get it
had Bill Maher Politically Incorrect you
remember that show before he [__] got
on HBO and got crazy and all that [__]
long ago and he used to have Carlin on
he used to have Larry Flint on
uh he had a lot of he had a lot of
right-wing crazies on so they can mock
them and make fun of them
that's kind of where I got my political
teeth as opinions but then I would watch
Carlin uh on HBO Carlin's specials and
uh I gotta tell you that uh there was no
one better at making you viscerally
think about an issue as the as the
comedy the late comedy of Carlin now
Carlin went through very many stages of
Comedy right he had different different
care comedy characters that he kind of
played you know different comedy but
when he got to the late 80s early 90s he
gave no more [__]
he did not give a [__] and he was going
to tell the world how he felt about the
world so uh John here asked was I
drinking Jaeger no I wasn't drinking
Jaeger last night believe it or not
I know the uh the audience knows that I
like Jagermeister
um it's one of my favorites taking shots
of Jaeger but no I didn't I didn't have
any I didn't have any of that
I didn't have any eagerness I just drank
a few beers just a couple beers and some
water I didn't get too blasted last
night
it was nice outside but boy it was warm
because there was a lot of people there
it was [__] packed and of course we
were dancing the whole goddamn time
because it was 90s hip-hop so how could
you not I could you not do that Rob Rob
says uh where's this guy with the last
name Sanchez I don't know oh he's he
says he says he'll uh he says he'll be
here quickly
he says he'll be here quickly and we got
a birthday in the chat it looks like
uh Linda Linda B Linda happy birthday to
you or no it's tomorrow tomorrow's your
birthday but happy happy early birthday
to you Linda happy birthday to you
um uh Mad Max said I thought it would be
Andrew Dice Clay
uh Andrew Dice Clay
you know the character the character
that he did because Andrew Dice Clay is
kind of like Larry the Cable Guy Like
Larry the Cable Guy that's not actually
who he is that's just a over an
exaggeration of him that's a character
same way as Andrew Dice Clay
uh but I do like Andrew Dice Clay's
um nursery rhymes
twinkle twinkle little star how I wonder
what you are if you know what I'm
talking about you know what the next
line is but I can't say it here on
YouTube can I
[Music]
um
okay do we have any more questions in
the in the chat
um yeah Christopher says it looks like
his favorite comedians are Carlin Lewis
Black Chappelle
uh Murphy Eddie Murphy and Sinbad
Sinbad's great I've seen Sinbad live
I've seen simban live went to St Louis
one time
I believe it was for like a bachelor
party or something and I wouldn't seen
Sinbad Sinbad's hilarious and Sinbad is
like really um
he's really personable it's like at the
end of the show somebody just sit back
and he'll let you ask him questions and
he'll answer anything like he was
answering any even controversial
questions like about his relationships
and [__] so Sinbad's a really cool dude
seen him in person uh Lenny Bruce of
course Lenny Bruce's uh Buster here says
Lenny Bruce on Facebook he says yeah I
like Lenny Bruce but Lenny Bruce really
paved the way uh for George Carlin and
for some of these other comedians he
really gave them the ability
uh to to to do that so
what did it do let's see what else do we
have what else do we have here do we
have any other questions
I like shooting the [__] with you guys
it's Friday why not shoot the [__]
what's some of the people on the left
attacking
what's with some of the people on life
attacking liberals what do you mean you
mean you mean like uh you mean like
leftists do you mean like Democratic
socialists they don't like they don't
like liberal
um because they think they think liberal
are the word liberal or liberals in
general or self-identified liberals they
think that they're they're not left
enough I think that's what you're asking
Rockefeller on on on Twitch
um maybe you're referring to like Hassan
[__] or or some of these other
commentators that are really their
Democratic socialists or socialist or
anti-capitalist
um you know they're they're in a
different time period right we're in
we're in a time period where uh
different ideologies
think
that they're going to Niche down and
Niche out and carve out a huge portion
of the population with the niche and
that's not exactly how ideology works
right
it can work that way I mean we see it
right now with the Trump cult right so
right now it feels like there's a huge
huge huge scourge
of uh fascism in our country but really
it's it's about 15 percent of the
country the tree believes in this
garbage
right they really do believe in it so
they've niched it down but the niche
ideology of fascism and trumpism
American fascism that is and the Trump
cult they their Niche has taken over the
party
so you can't and that would that's
that's why they were really mad about
Bernie right they were mad about Bernie
because uh they wanted Bernie's Niche to
take over the party well the problem is
when you have a niche take over a party
you have a problem like you do the
Republican party right now where they're
they're all [__] fascist and they
have to placate and they have to they
have to be the the dog of the Tail Wag
of this this nastiness this [__]
trash and this this hatred
um so that's that's why we have what we
have you know we're we're in a certain
period of time where political ideology
is is trying to figure out uh who and
where we're gonna be because the
two-party system
doesn't allow a lot of niche
uh uh uh ideologies right it doesn't
allow for that normally that that's what
that's why people like oh my God our
country is divided no we're not we're
not [__] divided that's all a bunch
of [__] that's the narrative from
the people who want you to believe that
it's divided
and again
I'll [__] bash on anyone I don't care
left right I don't care if they're
saying [__] like both sides or or the
countries divided in half they're full
of [__] [__] and they don't know what
they're talking about they're not good
commentators they're not they're just
not good commentators and they're not
very good at narrative to be quite
honest they're just they suck at it they
[__] suck at it the both sides
[__]
and and and the idea that our country is
divided in half that's a bunch of
[__]
that's a bunch of [__] so I hope
that's what you're asking about uh
people attacking liberals and that's why
I'll I mean a lot of people think I
attack the left when I attack tyt and
David packman [__] them they're not
they're not advancing they're not
advancing liberal democracy they're
advancing their own goddamn their own
goddamn self self-worth
let's see
oh um thank you Jose says thanks thanks
Tony the rush rush of the left a lot of
people call me the wrestling ball of the
lift there's a lot of people that have
that
um needy you say someone's having
trouble using Discord I don't know you
have to if you if you can't
um if you're having trouble using
Discord maybe maybe uh update the uh the
app or something
but sometimes discord's a little funny
so
sometimes discord's a little funny Rico
on Discord speaking of Discord
um Rico says I swapped David Pacman for
Tony Michaels thank you Rico
thank you Rico oh
the discord's blowing up in there ah
let's see
let's see who else do we have here do we
have any questions on the Discord
um
I'm just looking I'm just looking
well let's see here Tony went into the
city Tony TV says Tony went to the city
what's that mean what do you think I'm
some kind of country bumpkin that I live
out in the middle of nowhere I don't
live out in the middle no I mean I live
in the middle but not in the middle of
nowhere
I have internet and [__] we got
electricity here we don't have dirt
floors at the house that's funny uh when
I was uh
when I was in college I went to visit my
friend in in Chicago he was going to a
school up there and when we went to a
house party
and there there was there was a girl
there and we were kind of you know
flirting or whatever at the party and
she said that she said do you do you
guys have like indoor plumbing I was
like what the [__] well yeah why
wouldn't we have indoor plumbing she's
like I don't know just this how you
sound because she was from Chicago she
said just how you sound I'm like
God damn
God damn assume uh Buster here on
Facebook says uh Sam Kennison
a lot of people have said that I I
sometimes remind them of saying kidism
because he would just scream
Kennison would but kennison's hilarious
another one that died way too soon
another Mastermind of Comedy
that died way too soon what else what
other questions do we have here
if you guys got a question throw it in
the chat
and I'll talk to you here I'll answer
your questions here on shoot the [__] on
this Friday
what else do we have
uh yeah someone says Lewis Black Is
Awesome on uh uh twitch so one of the
things that I like about Lewis Black
course I don't know does he do this
anymore he used to be on The Daily Show
he used to do a segment called back in
Black where he would just do like a red
face rant the guy's just [__] losing
his mind
I don't know I I guess I take my
inspiration from so many greats right
Carlin Lewis Black
you know same Kennison
I don't know I think maybe maybe that's
maybe that's where I get it
man this is where I get it it's just my
inspiration from all the greats and it's
kind of all just kind of culminated into
this show
uh Tara here on Facebook says Tony or
Tony are your parents Democrats just
curious if you grew up in a family with
your ideology so my mom is a liberal uh
my dad is kind of an old style
Republican but the thing is my dad
[__] hates Trump
like [__] hates him and not just like
hates him now like has always hated that
[__] and the reason why is
because my dad [__] hates spoil that
silver spoon [__]
you know people who were born with the
[__] silver spoon in their mouth and
claim their self-made and [__] he
[__] hates that [__]
I mean vehemently hates that [__]
so
so my dad has never been a fan of trump
now he probably I would imagine that my
dad probably voted for
probably voted for Ronald Reagan both
times I mean I've never asked him this
but I'm sure he voted for uh bush
senior he probably voted for Bush senior
or Perot
I would imagine he he voted for Bob Dole
he probably voted for Bush both times
and he probably voted for McCain may
even voted for Mitt Romney I'm not
really sure I'm never really asking you
know personally
um but I do know one thing
he never voted for that [__]
Donald Trump because he [__] hates
that some [__]
hates that some [__]
so I don't I don't know if that matters
but and of course my mom's a my mom's a
real a real liberal like Lefty liberal
and she just
um she she [__] She [__] hates
hates Republicans she used to not hate
him so much but with Donald Trump and
Maga just can't partly [__] stand up
we got a lot of we got a lot of Maga in
our family
you know because we're from Central
Missouri
it's [__] delusional country right I
mean we got some cute enough people who
turned to Cuban on and [__] it's
unbelievable
but you know
you can't you can't uh focus on every
single thing you just gotta keep
fighting
uh Stone Child creation says like tyt
you like tyt or something's like Duty I
don't know uh Christopher Smith says
Rodney Dangerfield Rodney was great too
you know you know a fun fact about
Rodney Dangerfield is Rodney Dangerfield
didn't become famous till he was like in
his 40s and 50s he was like he was like
a a
sighting salesman for years siding in
paint I think is what he sold for years
before he actually became a famous
comedian now Christy here on YouTube
says Robin Williams Oh Robin Williams is
one of the greats too
oh my God so so so [__] great so
[__] great
let's see who else we get
uh uh
uh yeah and Gustav says crystal ball is
attacking Joe Biden now yeah well that
look there all these all these people
out there that claim to be liberals or
whatever commentators
they're attacking Biden is their goal is
the No Label [__]
mark my words this is their stupid ass
goal they've been convinced that someone
can run on this no labels ticket
and they oh man they can win that's like
this Marianne Williams and [__] from tyt
get the [__] out of here tyt ran on that
I think she's still on their shows
acting like she's gonna be the president
of the United States or some [__] get
the [__] out of here Marion Wilson never
had a goddamn chance
never had a damn chance and won't
Gavin Newsom couldn't beat Biden in a
primary what the [__] makes Marianne
Williams and think she's gonna be biting
in a primary and what the hell makes any
commentator out there
with two brain cells to rub together not
to know that Biden's gonna be the
nominee if you're out there talking
about how Biden's not gonna be nominee
you're a dumb [__]
you're just dumb as dog [__] I'm sorry I
you know you may not want him to be the
nominee you may not want that to be the
thing but if you're saying like he's not
gonna be that's the dumbest [__] I've
ever heard of in my life you don't know
how Democratic primary elections work
if you're saying that [__] you just
don't know
either that or you haven't looked it up
yet you're just ignorant of the facts
and the fact is Joe Biden is going to be
the nominee that's just how it's going
to be [__] like it or not if you
want someone else then Focus your energy
on 2028
for a democratic nominee but there is
not going to be a [__] primary
challenge to Biden okay
it's not how Democratic primaries work
when we elect a democratic prize
president the Democratic priority allows
that president to run for two terms just
like the Republican Party does but the
Democrats make sure make sure that the
incumbent president can win and the
reason why is because in incumbency is
one of the best advantages
so why the [__] do you think the party's
gonna be like you know what you know
what oh these three people on tyt are
right these three people on tyt right
let's let's subvert our whole system and
our whole party and what the actual
card-caring party members want and let's
just do what they want get the [__] out
of here
is it right I don't know is that the way
it should be maybe you should change it
but it's it's not you're not going to
change it now
what are you talking about
um
uh press Alpha on YouTube says would you
accept a Tony if it was awarded if Tony
was given a Tony Award ah sure why not I
don't know you'd think someone would
give me a Tony do you think someone
would award me with anything
come on listen I know how much you guys
love me and the reason why are you love
to hate me one of the other you either
love me or you love the hate me that's
kind of that's kind of how I've lived my
entire [__] life
but you I
most people don't like me
they don't like me even the people here
listening to what I'm saying half the
time even though it's cathartic for you
and you're like well he says the [__] I
want to hear and how I want to say it
but I can't really say it that way most
times
hmm
so
what else do we got here we're getting
to the top of the hour Gabe Sanchez
should be joining us soon
yeah uh
let's see what else do we got here
oh here you go Kevin says uh Tony say
hello to your Canadian on us we stand
with you the left Kevin listen I know
there's a ton of folks that that listen
in Canada now when I go when I go look
at the numbers and like where everyone's
listening there's a ton of people in
Canada that listen to the show and
there's ton of people you know did you
know people are up right now it's like
four o'clock in the morning in Australia
and they're listening live right now
they get up in the morning early to come
listen to this [__] I can't believe it
but they do they do
uh uh buster ass again has the guy with
the last name Sanchez ever done stand up
I don't know I don't know that he's done
stand up we can ask him we can ask him
when he gets on here we'll ask him if
he's done stand up just remind me give
me a quick reminder when he gets on here
we'll uh we'll try
let's see he's late he said 15 minutes
like 20 minutes ago this [__] guy you
know what I mean he may not have done
stand up I just give him [__] you know a
lot of people think that when I give
Gabe [__] I'm serious about it I'm not
I'm just giving him a hard time I'm just
really trying to give the guy [__] you
should you should see sometimes our chat
[Laughter]
like our our private text messages I
don't go any easier on him there either
uh let's see
oh uh here's a good question super Saint
says Bill Hicks yes Bill Hicks is
[__] badass but Bill X had a crazy he
was on a lot of drugs like he was doing
a lot of hallucinogens and [__] so like
sometimes Bill hicks's mind was way the
[__] out there like way the [__] out
there and and everyone's asking how how
long hat weeks last here's here's the
[__] I'm hat I don't have it on today
but here's the [__] I always have a
[__] hat right here handy but it is
it is [__] hat week you go to hats
not store not hats.d Tony michaels.com
excuse me hats.d Tony michaels.com and
you use the promo code hat week now
that's hat week now to get 10 off and
it's through the weekend
so you can get your [__] hats all
weekend long get them 10 off use hat
week now at the hat store you can go to
the Tony michaels.com click on the
[__] hat store link or go to
hatch.dtonymichaels.com use the promo
code hat week now to get 10 off uh Gabe
Sanchez someone was just asking
foreign
it is over
oh God damn he's got his mic in the
right you were you were like jumbled
that's what I was like what are you
saying what no your mic was jumbled no
let the audience the audience can hear I
believe that Tony was jumbled there was
he not I don't know
did I have [__] in my mouth did I have
[__] I sounded like you had [__] in your
mouth oh okay someone's saying audio so
maybe maybe it's right yeah Tony was
jumbled see I'm not the only one man
what the [__] I don't know what to tell
there I don't tell you so there was a
question we were doing uh shoot the [__]
here and they were asking when will we
meet in person no no no no I saw that
one in the Discord uh it's it's like
we're gonna go on a date or something I
know when are we when are we finally
gonna get this Arrangement should we
make it like a romance thing where we
have like roses and [__] and yeah you
know like uh you know uh I can be on a
Terrace and you can be like down below
and I'd be like oh Tony oh Tony Where
Art Thou Tony
do you know how do you know how much I
love making public
especially other people in public really
[__] uncomfortable oh I love making
people oh yeah if you want to do it man
let's do it oh man I love making people
feel uncomfortable like take them to the
edge like to a boundary you know what I
mean I do I do like like we're in a
group sometimes and like everyone's you
know standing around a fire drinking
chatting oh man I'll [__] make
everyone just feeling good I remember
there I think it was a Halloween party
we were at one time this is a it's
probably about eight ten years ago
something like that we're standing
around and I'm talking about how you
know how you know you need a shower
right how do you know how do you know
you need a shower how do you figure it
out is there something that you do yeah
I mean you know you can go like this I
do that I do the smell test but I don't
I don't I don't sniff my pits and you
got to really get down deep in there
like Rudy Giuliani God and you gotta you
know you gotta tuck yeah one yeah you
gotta tuck down there and get the real
you gotta you gotta get this with the
taint you gotta if there if there's if
there's a place on the body that is
gonna give you a good indicator a good
thermometer of rather you need a [__]
shower or not it is the taint I feel
like damn sure ninety percent of the
time anytime you 90 of the time it works
every time well so you're saying so
you're saying my tank smells bad 90 of
times is that what you're saying
probably Tony no probably no dude I
check it three four times a day what do
you think I'm doing during commercial
break here what do you think I'm doing
over here during commercial break I'm
making sure that I'm still fresh gotta
gotta take a shower after the show man
why do you think sometimes I wrap it up
really quick I gotta go get in the
shower man my taint smells like [__] I
mean knowing that you live in you know
out in the [__] Ozarks here there I
feel like during the summer uh you can
drink as many showers in the day that
you wanted every time you're done I'd be
like well did you really drink drain the
smart grass drain the swamp ass that's
all I'm asking that's all I'm at how do
we go from you doing stand-up to talking
about smelling my taint how the hell did
you get there I don't when were we
talking about stand-ups I asked the the
audience asked if you've ever done
stand-ups they asked me who my favorite
comedian was on on on shoot the [__] and
we were talking about Comedians and then
they asked if you have ever done stem
and I said I don't think he does
probably even I don't think he's done so
I uh when I first moved to LA I did
stand up a little bit there was a there
was a spot here that was like the whole
premise you would go in completely
improvised so you'd get on stage you
would have a bucket of suggestions of
either a phrase or one word statements
or whatever and you'd pick the topic out
and then you'd have to riff and do a
stand-up set you could pick as many
topics as you want out it is you're like
all right I I did that uh I did that
joke I want to go through again in terms
of actually going up and being like
right I got a whole like tied five to do
I've never never done that I've done
just more improvised stuff it's always
been like on my list of like what
comedic routine have I not done yet and
like that's the one where I go into
I'm like man I would like to
but I just like never have the time to
like write down the jokes that I want to
say most of the jokes end up going into
a [__] what was that you know you
know you could probably put together
some of your best for from what was that
and and get you know you could probably
get 20 minutes probably I mean every
every episode that I make for what was
that I'm always like
how do I make
this one funnier even if it's one part
and it could be the dumbest of jokes and
I'm like God it's such a [__] dumb
such a dumb joke and then I'm like but I
had a laugh yeah but it works right
if it triggers that feeling of laughter
Oh don't and don't worry this one that
I've got coming up for Rudy Giuliani oh
boy is this one that you put in the chat
is this one I'm gonna put in the chat is
the one that I released yesterday okay
so that one's and that one's the latest
one but there's another one that I'm
working on right now that I've got to
finish up writing the script for uh
that's about Rudy Giuliani and I cover
everything from basically the guys in
financial and uh reputable bankruptcy
he is losing everything and it's all
because he decided to latch on to the
Trump wagon
and so there's a lot of a lot of a lot
of interesting stuff that's coming out
of it well you know that there there's
news about uh cheese burrow yes yeah I
threw him making them latching onto a
wagon he makes a cameo in this week's
bonehead I don't know I don't know if um
if Alex Jones is off the wagon I'm sure
he's
yeah I'm sure he's back off I don't know
but I I will say this
uh uh Jacob chancelly and Alex Jones
wait wait you mean you mean the uh
Shaman yeah kyunan Shaman yeah
and also
Alex Jones they he went on a show and
Alex Jones was unwilling to accept the
crazy conspiracies that that the kunan
shaman was saying wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait are
you telling me there is footage of Alex
Jones being like you're a crazy
[__] I can't believe the [__]
you're saying I I I'm the king of
conspiracy theory and you're telling me
you're telling me this crazy [__] hold
on I do a pretty good Alex Jones I don't
know I mean let me a lot of people say
I'm a lot of people say I'm the
wrestling ball a lot but have you say
I'm the Alex Jones
of the left do I spend that many
conspiracy theories do I you might I
mean you know I'm talking about my taint
today that's one thing but I don't I
don't put on my 10 bull hat I talk about
my taint
so I don't know if that's what style
that is
hold on I'm looking for this video
because I know I saw it in here the
other day when you sent me that one clip
of him
I went in a deep dive right oh yeah I
sent you the video of where where the Q
Anon shamani dressed up as the Joker and
he's taken Clips yeah show me like show
me years ago
what yeah and also show me that's weird
show me you watch The Dark Knight
and didn't understand the Joker without
telling me you watched The Dark Knight
and didn't understand the Joker he
thinks he thinks it's a good thing that
he's the Joker in that video now someone
on Twitch says taint foil hat that's
what it is I don't have a tinfoil hat I
have a taint foil hat this is true this
is true
no Tony you're not like Jones
no well it's not like like I do my [__]
like him now I will tell you I um you
[__] like him huh do [__] well I mean I
mean we all everyone kind of shits the
same right I don't know do people [__]
standing up
most people said who knows depends on
the situation uh anyways
off the uh that topic
um uh uh you know what's funny is our
friend Justin t Brown sent me a graphic
and I think I sent it to you and it's
this uh it's this organization what the
hell is it called maybe I should bring
it up here I don't know did you send it
to me yeah I sent it to you and they
said I'm the most extreme or some [__]
oh you remember this you remember this
it's the um it's the one that rates all
of the like podcasts and news yeah yeah
they rate podcasts and [__] and they
said um on there right oh [__] did they
did they oh my God they think I'm the
most extreme left but you know what's
interesting about that if you look on
that if you look on that chart if you go
all the way to the right yeah look at
who you find
well I that's what I'm trying to say
here let me see if I can um I'm just
gonna pull it up here it's not gonna be
a pretty graphic but
ah that that here it is see let me pull
this up
see if we can get this going I'll show
Nance girl now what's up this is uh
again yeah add Fontes that's what it is
yeah at Fontes is the uh is the is the
dealio but you see us over there on the
um well I guess uh
what the [__]
um maybe I'll post this on social media
so you can see it oh it's it's uh yeah
you know what [__] this [__]
let's take that down let me post it on
Twitter so everyone can see this thing
really quick I'm just gonna post just
the graphic here that way you can see
this some [__] and I'll pull it up in
Twitter so we can zoom in on it and [__]
there we go okay so you can you can make
what you want of this thing here
um but if you look at it close
see if I can get it up here here it is
there we go okay so if you look down
here there's the Tony Michaels podcast
here here's our here's our rival tyt uh
the Palmer report let's see what else do
we got all in with Chris Hayes is right
here you see that uh let's see what's
some what's some other familiar ones
MSNBC vouch belt ali belchi uh let's see
who else do we got here and up here at
the top you got CNN NBC PBS baby Pew
Research Center down here down here at
the bottom in the center you got Joe
Rogan and [__] what's his name uh
Russell Brand really they're in the
middle get the [__] out of here with
this [__] the middle you know it's
because he's got that British accent or
like
I feel like hold on it wasn't there some
didn't I look something up about them
and I was like oh they actually there's
something about this organization who
I don't know I don't know I mean do I
take this very seriously no but I think
um if if any if if anyone that's gonna
you know evaluate media they put me in
the exact spot that I want to be to be
quite honest but I want to show Nance
girl this
so here here we are right here okay if
you look at the chart here it says
contains misleading info if you mean
about my taint then yeah maybe uh when
we're talking about taint and stuff that
maybe this because that's probably not a
good way to know if you need a shower or
not I'm not gonna lie I'd be curious I
mean who knows maybe we did report on
something but it could be I would I
would like to know what misleading info
is there because we're pulling from
sources right that you find in the top
base my commentary off reports from this
group of [__] up here right but
if you look if you look here it says
containing misleading info I think this
is the thing that would piss off the
lefties not liberals but lefties you
know like Democratic socialists Bernie
Bros people who love tyt and Marianne
Williamson it says most extreme left so
I'm more extreme left than tyt that
would piss them the [__] off I really
think this would piss them off like how
in the [__] is he more left than us but
also if you listen if you no I don't
think so but I mean like if you really
took it a moment to listen yeah to what
they say and we obviously you know we go
after tyt for all this stuff especially
as of late right uh the things that
they've said it's not on it's not
surprising at least to me it wouldn't be
surprising to be like oh yeah the
commentary that they have on this show
is left of t YT because tyt is somewhere
that is you know not left or at least
not full left where they have this idea
of
going after trans rights or you know
injecting transphobia or trying to be
more in the center in order to have this
like No Labels forward party type of
[__] right well you know the other
thing too that I just noticed Jimmy Dore
is right above me and Jimmy door is
anything but most extreme left right now
like this this does not bode well for
their thing but I want to show I want to
show the audience something here uh
based on what uh naps girl said so you
see me right here Donnie Michael's
podcast right there Boom at less and
then you know uh all the way left but if
you span over just a little bit right
here right there it says Inver Wars
at least we're if anything if anything
I'll take that were over triggered right
well so we're we're we're we're we're
we're we are diametrically opposed if
you want to say that from this chart
from triggered Tim cast Dan bongino
Infowars and some of the others here
like hand vaccine news
you know you know what after looking at
this uh because there was a different
version I think that we had in February
that I that I posted yeah of this and we
were in the exact same spot so like we
haven't moved since February so so I'm
still getting the same rating from these
[__] in August that I was
getting February so I'm doing my job
right I think is the uh is the the point
of that but you know what I noticed
there's a lot of [__] missing
from this
from the left quote the left right
there's a lot of [__] that
aren't on this thing
so it kind of it kind of makes me feel
good that even this [__] whatever
this is advantis Media because what I
know what they're trying to do they're
trying to pick out you know the people
that are you know oh my God he sounds
like right wing talk radio that's what
tells me the most about this is that
like our show has the exact right tone
right that that's what I because there's
there's podcasts that are written that
get way more [__] attention than we
do that aren't on this [__]
they're not on this [__] and you
know why it's because I hate to say it
like this but they're [__] boring
they're boring they're [__] boring we
are not boring we talk about politics
and taints uh here on the Tony Michaels
podcast so that is very true so that's
the um the ad Fontes uh media I think
they're out of Arizona
if you want to know maybe they're not
where are they out of L.A look them up
uh it's uh I'm looking I'm looking at
pontesmedia.com about us yeah about us
what about them they know a lot about me
but let's find out about them what what
do we know I wouldn't be very interested
to see someone like I'm always
interested to be like oh what's your
like what's the algorithm or what's the
rating system you decide this stuff on
oh like like how do they put oh yeah
like you could figure out their
methodology uh all right so contact us
let's see
their numbers are seven seven two oh
seven two oh area code yeah is Denver
that's what that's oh they're in Denver
so I don't know if they're in well
that's what they're that's what their
phone number says I'm just double
checking I see I see I see contact us
Jesus Christ come on man
you don't know they don't want you to
know where they are yeah we're on the
internet that's all that matters
yeah just take what we say seriously uh
let's see I'm gonna post this so
everyone can see it in the Discord too
this uh picture if you guys want to see
it oh maybe
now there it is maybe maybe there I'm
gonna post it on Discord here so if you
guys want to go over Discord you can see
it there too and you spread that graphic
around hell why not yeah Lafayette
Colorado
Lafayette Colorado yeah Colorado
uh-huh
well if you guys want to go into the
Discord it's I I post east of Boulder
east of Boulder yeah does it say like
what their mission is what's their
mission with their little graph and
chart that they got and I wonder who
it's funded by hmm
that's a good question I bet it's our
team of over 60 analysts rates the news
day in and day out and then they have a
whole video do you do you that's that's
that's the greatest thing honestly hey
you know what let's let's go with that
we're news
we're not no news
media generate the scores for each news
source on the media buys tour we
generate overall new scores based on
scores of individual articles in the
case of online news articles or episodes
in the case of podcast Radio TV here's
the thing that I don't know see this is
why I don't believe this this means that
their team of 60 people are watching our
show two hours every day to make sure
that it's the most accurate what I would
imagine is being done is right
I don't know if it is our current team
over 60 analysts who are trained in our
current our content analyst methodology
perform the ratings our analysts go
through an initial 30 hours of training
plus an additional 40 hours of ongoing
training per year
our analysts include academic
journalists Librarians lawyers military
veterans Civil Service professionals and
other professionals that require high
levels of rhetorical and analytical
skills each individual article and
episode that is rated by a pod of at
least three human analysts at the same
time each pod is politically balanced I
mean it contains one person who
identifies to the right one in the
center one on the left articles and
episodes are rated in three person live
panels conducted in shifts over Zoom
analysts first read each article and
write them on their own then immediately
compare scores and if there's
discrepancy in the scores they discuss
and adjust the scores if necessary the
three analysts ratings
are average to produce an overall
article rating sometimes articles are
rated by larger panelists of analysts
for various reasons for example if there
are outlier scores the article may be
rated by more than three analysts so
they're picking and choosing which
episode or which article to review
because they can't honestly go through
all of them
and so what I would imagine is happening
is like for most of the stuff that
happened that comes out of CNN right has
been Center left however recently you
might find stuff that's more like center
right
with our show I would imagine they're
picking an episode depending on what the
episode topic is and going through
and then doing it that way because
there's no way that they're going in
periodically and checking let's just
pick this one episode they're probably
okay so this is this is a good point now
um I'm gonna go to our local librarian
here in the Tony Michaels yeah yeah you
said Librarians My Librarian over on
Discord is saying they're not a
political organization they're regular
database companies that compiles
information and she says for [__] sake
I attend their vendor events so
um yeah there's photos of them at like
vendor boots on on this website
but that's the that's
that's what it really comes see here's
the deal is Gabe Gabe here doesn't like
where we're placed I like we're replaced
to be quiet I don't like okay here's why
I don't like our place I don't like okay
okay I like if there was anything if
there was any reason we'd be flagged as
misinformation misleading info it was
when we did the thing about Lauren
bobert
and when we shared the stuff about the
uh the press release that I made about
Trump
the what
the the oh because oh because we [__]
because you made it as a joke so if I'm
thinking if I'm thinking right if I'm
thinking of moments at which they say
this is inaccurate this is misleading
info I look at this and I say okay if I
go through the show right we're giving
an opinion but we're also it's a
left-leaning opinion and we're talking
about what's going on yes we make jokes
and we're not saying that it's true to
the news but we report on it to say
these sources CNN ABC Reuters NPR Fox
News uh the guardian BBC
you know
anything else also uh right right wing
extremist uh type of channels and voices
we report on what they're saying that we
give commentary on it we're not
misleading any information we're giving
opinion
but it's also not misinformation so when
I think back I'm like running a catalog
of every show that we've done the only
times I would ever look at a situation
and say did we do something that was
intentionally misleading or
misinformation and I'm like maybe that
one time that we reported on Lauren
bobert which by the way still is a big
question mark on whether that's true or
not because they're the the creator of
the uh what's the organization called
the market Breakers yeah muckrakers is
taking or has taken Lauren bobert to
court no I don't know what the status is
well apparently apparently Lauren Boomer
did what she said what in the moment is
that she was going to sue them now for
people who don't know this is when um
this is the moment when uh Warren
Buffett has been accused allegedly to uh
of been an escort for Ted Cruz yeah yeah
and then also allegedly accused of uh
having abortions in in uh abortion
clinics in Colorado now I all I did
to be fair alls I did was just report
what was in or say what was in the Tweet
now
what's funny about that is that um I
took down the tweet and the people who
have that pack contacted me said why do
you take down a tweet I said because one
of the pictures that you're claiming is
Lauren bobert is not Lauren bobert yeah
I've confirmed that it is not Lauren
bobert
so I took down the Tweet which I don't
Gabe knows I don't just [__] take
down tweets like I don't care how
misspelled it is I don't give a [__] if
it looks stupid I don't even care if I
misdo your or whatever I don't give a
[__] I'm not gonna take it down but I
took that one down because she
threatened the sue people yeah and I was
and and the re the reason why I took it
down is because I knew I went and looked
at the pictures and I knew for sure at
one point that it wasn't her so I'm like
well it's not her I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna leave it up if it's not her making
people think that it is her yeah so
technically technically I did not I did
not want to mislead anyone once I
figured out that it was I didn't give a
big retraction so then maybe that's
where they're getting a thing so when I
because that's the [__] news this is
this is why when I look at this I'm like
what it was misleading or where did we
have misinformation and there are two
moments the Lauren bobert thing we're
like all right Greg we pulled it that
was fine and then the other time or
times but the main one was when and I
you know Hoodwinked the internet uh
really over the over the Donald Trump
which time was it was that the time that
uh Seth Abrams got really funny that was
the one that caused him to block me tell
all of his followers to block me the one
he did leave it like an hour-long
Instagram live and then he went on
Instagram live this guy with the last
name [__] jizz he doesn't know comedy
Steph Abrams was explaining to his
audience what comedy is and isn't it
yeah on like an hour-long Instagram
because he really went on a rant because
people were like oh and he was like I've
been getting death threats I was like
who is threatening you over this no one
is [__] threatening you no one's I
told him to [__] off yeah he's like I've
been threatened so much and I was like
don't give me that [__] victim whiny
ass
at you stop being a little baby and stop
trying to make it seem like you're more
important than you really are I made a
joke a lot of people fell for it a lot
of people didn't fall for it and the
person that claw that calls themselves a
journalist AKA Seth Abramson he said oh
well I just posted it and I didn't fact
check it well that's not on me man if
you're a journalist you're a reporter
you should be doing the due diligence to
look up the facts if you didn't check
your social
and then you look over here look over
there on what people were saying and
didn't follow to be like oh looks like
the source started from Gabe Sanchez I
should probably uh I don't know ask his
profile click on his profile what a
[__] bonehead you know the best part
about that is he whined and cried for an
hour in the Instagram chat yeah and the
Instagram live and we were watching it
and we were like commenting like yeah
hey we're right here dude you can talk
to us and he you know he wasn't paying
attention
um so My Librarian says this on Discord
she said they're looking at a commentary
that is technically far left we're
technically far left which I can agree
with that we're definitely far left just
because something is far right or far
left commentary doesn't always make it
disinformation it's just noting the
political bias so I think what what
mining librarian is saying here is that
they're not noting that it's that it's
misleading info what they're saying is
it's far left yeah
political bias because my commentary
from my political bias not from a from a
uh you know that that's that's fine when
I look at this chart then if you're
gonna make that claim right as as this
Advantage if you're gonna make the claim
if you're gonna label things because
labeling is is very uh very very like
important here when you have this this
chart and you say here's the quadrant in
terms of left right uh less
informational more informational then
you better make sure that the labels you
put on there
are not misleading
or aren't misinformation so if it really
is to be like oh it's left lending
opinion then put its opinion don't put
misinformation because misinformation
when I when I see misinformation I imply
that to be true to the label that it is
saying that we are misinforming our
Audience by telling them
falsehoods again I don't know if there's
talking about misleading info on the
politics and the facts or about uh porns
and taint I'm not really sure it could
be something could they could have a
point I mean I could I haven't watched
this I haven't I have not watched their
their methodology video but I could
probably assume that uh it's not totally
strong I mean even the fact that they're
like we have 60 analysts and we review
them in PODS of three well how are you
reviewing
10 hours of show
or plus of this show plus other things I
I can only imagine they're picking and
choosing based on what might be trending
uh what they've been sent or when they
just randomly go in and pick something
and they decide oh you know what this is
the rating that we gave it so I don't
know I I have an issue with it
especially when I I knew I knew I knew
Gabe Gabe does not like this chart yeah
he does not like it but that's why I
don't like it it's not because we're on
the left it's because the labels on this
chart are misleading
right like I just find I just find it
ironic that they're going to be like oh
this is misleading info when you have if
it truly is to say this is opinion and
not actual like facts of the situation
then have opinion don't have to do info
no we should do we should invite someone
from ad Fontes on the show well at add
fun just higher add fonte or whatever
her name is she's the CEO and founder
and there's no one else that they like
identify as people who work there well
because I don't think they actually work
there's just a bunch of people that it
could be a bunch of mechanical Turks
they could be hiring it but that's
another thing if people don't know this
like you're like oh look the algorithm
is working this way it could be a bunch
of manual labor mechanical Turks that
you hire for people to do those things
for you that's why a lot of people a lot
of rumors early on that Pandora wasn't
actually an algorithm it was actually
people choosing your music so so My
Librarian points out something she says
it's not meant for your audience meaning
our audience the audience here it's
meant for scholarly research resources
in K-12 education so and and what
they're doing and the reason why we're
we are where we are on the chart is
because they're they're looking through
the lens that we think and they think
where news
and we we are not news yeah but
apparently they want to frame us that
way so again in that in that perspective
if they're looking at us as a news
organization like CNBC or or whoever our
MSNBC or CNN or PBS or NBC or BBC or
whatever all these people at the top
here that's if that's what they're
really looking for that through the lens
that we are then again Gabe doesn't like
it but I think we're in the exact right
spot that we need to be I'm excited I
would be curious to know what the
interactive chart looks like
huh because here's a so interactive yeah
there's an interactive chart that goes
with this oh is there this is license
for social media sharing only so it's a
static image but fully licensed copies
and interactive chart are available when
you pay them so I'd be curious what
happens like when you hover over these
objects which are the thumbnails and the
titles like
do they have a numerical rating system
or is it just a qualitative rating like
what is it you know well it could be it
could be uh Miss loveseek in the Discord
makes a good point tell them you're
making fun of the news and politicians
not actually that's what that's
basically what we do we just make fun of
the [__] I don't and I say all the
time like look I don't make the news I
don't get to make the news I don't know
what I I all I do is just pull the news
[__] talk about it make fun of it for
your enjoyment your cathartic release
and give you some sort of [__]
[Laughter]
oh man storm Virgil on Twitch says
counter opinion [__] Advantage media
question mark I don't know that could be
I I'm I don't I I know Gabe doesn't like
this this is why I wanted to bring it
because he doesn't like this yeah this
really gets in his crawl you know what
it's because if you're gonna report on
something then be accurate about it well
you know what we should do we should get
him to do what was that
see where what was that falls in on this
shirt maybe that would make you feel
more comfortable they're going to be
like oh there's too many jokes and
there's too much even though I report
the facts and I show my sources then
they're like oh this is this is not good
this is they're gonna it's like well
what do you think like a late night show
like uh Last Week Tonight or a closer
look or the daily
shows are they're not on there no
they're not I don't think so like if I
look at this Jimmy Dore he's a comedian
and he and Jimmy or or well I don't know
he would like to consider himself that
maybe uh I don't see any right is there
any uh Russell Brandon and [__] Joe
Rogan are comedians
I can't believe you know what you know
what discredits this whole thing for me
is that they're in the middle
get the [__] out of here yeah you're in
the middle and and you know what this is
a good point too is that is that really
podcasts should probably not be on this
thing like
we're not a news organization I'm not
I'm not I don't claim to be a news man
or anything like that I'm just well if
you're gonna or or what they should do
is they could just make ones that are
podcast specific right right so they
could do a a instead of a media media
bias chart they could do a podcast type
yeah bias chart that way they could show
the bias of a podcast and we probably
land a little differently on this
probably but uh but you know what maybe
maybe we will try to see if we can get
what was that we can get them to uh put
what was that on this that way um
yeah except that they put me on there
and they put me in the wrong place I
would be hilarious if you're like more
extreme left and way more misleading
information than this show that would be
great that would be great that would
really piss Gabe Sanchez off I get a lot
of laughs out of it to be quiet yeah you
get a lot of laughs I'd give him [__]
what's the point of what's the point of
researching and saluting the internet to
get the facts get it wrong if I get it
wrong according to them well you know
which is which is the whole point which
is the whole point of what was that it's
to I I sleuth the internet I don't know
I don't know listen I can vouch for a
game
that those what was that he puts more
time in the actual figuring out what
he's saying is true then then him
actually saying it recording it editing
it and then playing it that is true
there's a lot more there's a lot more
into it speaking of that a lot of stuff
should we play this uh speaking of what
was that should we play this one and
then come back and do bonehead do you
have enough time
okay I didn't I didn't know what your
schedule we want to go the full three
hours today it looks like it it's
looking that way I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna
I'm not I'm not gonna lie I mean I'm not
gonna mislead you here
you know what I mean even though even
though I had Fontes says that we do
mislead I'm not going to mislead you uh
in this effort to uh to uh get what was
that going so and bonehead as well so um
let's uh let's see let's get to this
gets cued up
there it is okay I'm sure we're gonna
have ads in this so um should I go I
need to get that ad blocker yeah you get
that ad blocker so I saw we played one
of the episodes yesterday or the other
day and someone was like uh
I don't like the ads I was like I can't
control that
that's used to me
yeah I own it Tony I'm the problem it's
me how does the song go hello hi hi oh
yeah hello it's me I'm hi I'm the
problem it's me yeah I'm always the the
problem so here's here is speaking of a
problem
here's Gabe Sanchez in the latest uh
what was that
everyone welcome to what was that I'm
Gabe Sanchez Donald Trump has been
indicted a fourth time on felony charges
in connection with efforts to overturn
the 2020 presidential election results
in Georgia and this one packs a [__]
punch good evening we're coming on the
air with breaking news out of Georgia
where former president Trump was just
indicted for the fourth time but before
we get into that make sure to like this
video subscribe to this Channel and ring
that notification Bell so you never miss
another episode Donald Trump has now
been indicted four times Well five times
if you count the superseding indictment
in the Mar-A-Lago class by documents
case and he now faces a total of 91
felony charges damn phony Willis has
charged Trump and 18 co-defendants with
a sweeping 41 felony counts and all I
can say is
now as much as I would have loved Bonnie
Willis to read their names like
contestants on a game show she was very
professional and set the bar for how to
handle these criminals this indictment
features all of the major Trump losers
but I just want to highlight a handful
that we knew would be in deep [__] since
day one John unconstitutional Eastman
Jeffrey pantsless Clark Sydney released
the Kraken Powell Rudy I married my
second cousin Giuliani and Jenna I
caught covid from Rudy's fart Ellis no
seriously just see for yourself well if
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness yeah you heard that sound right
witness witness witness now if you
thought Jack Smith was serious Bonnie
Willis is not messing around subsequent
to the indictment as is the normal
process in Georgia law the the grand
jury issued arrest warrants for those
who are charged
I am giving the defendants the
opportunity to voluntarily surrender no
later than noon on Friday the 25th day
of August
2023. so whether it's in handcuffs or
voluntarily surrendering Trump and his
18 coup plotters are coming to Georgia
and I can't wait to watch that perp walk
and according to the sheriff in Fulton
County it's going to be picture day we
are following our part of our normal
practices and so it doesn't matter your
status we'll we have mug shots ready for
it now I've read the 98 page indictment
and I definitely recommend that you do
as well but but this thing is a [__]
page Turner it has 30 unindicted
co-conspirators as well as 19 defendants
charged with 41 felony counts in a
sprawling Rico indictment let me just
repeat myself they are being charged
under
now some of you may remember learning
about Rico in the movie The Dark Knight
Rico
they pulled their money we can charge
them all as one criminal conspiracy
in a RICO case if you can charge one of
the conspirators with a felony you can
charge
but to break it down here's CNN's lawyer
coach spelling out what the charges
against Trump are and how the fact that
so many of his attorneys were named as
co-defendants could create trouble for
him because a fancy way of saying look a
whole bunch of people got together two
or more really got together and
coordinated a conspiracy it's conspiracy
on steroids as my friend Norm Eisen
likes to say it's a way of participating
in crimes two or more in Georgia as part
of an overall plan there are the overall
connection really is that you all engage
in criminal Behavior you need not have
direct connection with one another as
long as you're part of an overall
conspiracy or actual Enterprise think
about the common Mafia case right where
you've got one person who's a kind of
ringleader a puppeteer as you will
everyone attached to that string
involved in the entire theater really is
going to be at issue here the reason
it's so important here is because
normally a prosecutor only has the
jurisdiction in their own specific area
they have to be nearsighted for justice
to Prevail Rico allows you to be broader
because whatever you have engaged gen in
criminal behavior that I really had an
impact in my jurisdiction whether you
would happen out of state whether it was
different County whether it was
something in a a different you know
region of the country it all can count
towards my RICO case around me so it
does that also what's really interesting
here is look at the attorneys that are
named in this indictment so many
attorneys so many eternalists
Sydney Powell you know Giuliani just to
name a few um it's a Motley Crew of
attorneys and remember one of the
defenses we've been having is defensive
Council you know I was like you know
following the advice of counsel here
that's all I was really doing think
about the different schemes that are in
play and they're being charged what this
does now with all them being charged is
it puts at odds Donald Trump with his
counsel because at some point in fact
finding Mission has to ensue where you
have to prove that this was either by
the council or not oh and by the way a
RICO charge carries a sense of up to 20
years and Trump is 77. so I'll let you
do the math the indictment lays out the
plot chronologically listing various
efforts by Trump and the alleged
co-conspirators to overturn the results
in the state of Georgia now the subject
of this indictment will probably end up
being a few episodes in order to cover
the nuances characters and reactions but
so far the gop's freakout has been very
interesting to watch like Lindsey Graham
going on Fox News and saying that it's
very unfair to prosecute Trump but I
know this between Manhattan and Fulton
County and DC the most liberal
jurisdictions in the country is very
unfair to president Trump and shouldn't
this really be done by Statewide
official if there's a crime against the
people of Georgia shouldn't it be done
by somebody like the attorney general or
we're going to let County Prosecutors
start Prosecuting the president of the
United States the former president
United States you opened up Pandora's
box of the presidency this whole
exercise of allowing a County prosecutor
to go after former president of the
United States will do a lot of damage to
the presidency itself over time to my
Democratic friends be careful what you
wish for I'm actually surprised that
Lindsey Graham wasn't crying and begging
for money on behalf of trump like he
normally does I'm sorry I'm so upset but
please help president Trump if you could
afford five or ten bucks if you can't
afford a dollar fine just pray make sure
you vote as early as you can in your
state don't risk anything anymore vote
as soon as you can pray for this country
pray for this President and if you got
any money to give give it oh and don't
forget that in 2020 Graham allegedly
asked rappensberger and his staff about
re-examining certain absentee ballots
cast in Georgia in order to explore the
possibility of a more favorable outcome
for Trump so is Lindsey Graham an
unindicted co-conspirator in this
indictment who knows but what I do know
is that you don't do these types of
things unless Trump has something on you
especially when Graham made these
comments back in 2015. the bottom line
is that I believe Donald Trump would be
in absolute utter disaster for the
Republican Party destroy our
conservatism as we know it we would get
wiped out and it would take generations
to overcome a trump candidacy Ronald
Reagan had a three-legged stool of
conservatism fiscal social and strong
National Security Donald has a
four-legged stool because he's the
Donald it's got to be bigger economic
populism xenophobia race-baiting and
religious bigotry are the stool that he
has formed that is his campaign that is
not conservatism Ted Cruz in my view is
a real Republican who I often disagree
with I'm supporting Ted because I think
he's the best alternative to Donald
Trump and speaking of Ted Cruz he was
also on Fox news but he was cosplaying
as a reporter but you asked what my
reaction is I'm pissed I'm pissed at
these over and over and over again if
they're indictments tonight it'll be the
fourth indictment of Donald Trump this
is disgraceful our country is over 200
years old we have never once indicted a
former president or a candidate and a
leading candidate for president and this
is Joe Biden and this is the Democrats
weaponizing the justice system because
they're afraid of the voters this is
disgraceful it is wrong and it is a b an
abuse of power by Angry Democrats who
have decided the rule of law doesn't
matter to them anymore look Ted Cruz can
say that he's pissed about the
indictment but we all know it's fake
outrage the only reason he's there is to
promote his own podcast like a washed up
reality starhawken diet pills as you
know I do a podcast every week verdict
with Ted Cruz seriously the guy will
exploit any opportunity that he can to
promote his own podcast because
apparently being a U.S senator isn't
enough actually you know what if Ted
Cruz can do it then I feel like I can
take a quick moment to plug my patreon
as an independent Creator and a one-man
show I guarantee that I put more work
into researching writing filming and
editing this show than whatever Ted Cruz
does as a U.S senator so if you like
comedic sketches political satire or
just want to see more commentary of me
mocking Republicans like this make sure
to subscribe at patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez oh and I promise unlike Ted Cruz
I will not abandon you but beyond
Lindsey Graham and Ted Cruz on Fox News
there were countless other Republicans
who are up in arms about this indictment
but I just want to take a moment to
appreciate the irony of it all
specifically Rudy Giuliani who made his
career on using Rico to go after the mob
when he was a U.S attorney and now he's
been indicted on Rico charges himself
but that's not the only ironic part
about this indictment on the very same
night that Trump was indicted again
Hillary Clinton was scheduled to appear
on Rachel maddow's show all right fancy
meeting you oh I can't believe this yeah
this is not the circumstances in which I
expected to be talking to you nor me
Rachel it's always good to talk to you
but honestly
um I didn't think that it would be under
these circumstances yet another set of
indictments years of trump and mega
chanting lock her up have led to this
very moment Hillary Clinton free and
Donald Trump indicted a fourth time you
couldn't write this kind of karmic and
Poetic Justice if you tried but it also
comes with Hillary admitting great
sadness do you feel
satisfaction in that you warned the
country essentially that he was going to
try to end democracy but the most of the
country didn't believe you well it's
hard to believe I I don't feel any
satisfaction I feel great uh you know
just just great profound sadness that uh
we have a former president who has been
indicted for so many uh charges that
went right to the heart of whether or
not our democracy would survive and we
don't know yet what the charge is coming
out of Georgia are but if you stop and
think about what the public evidence is
and you've been talking about some of
that for the last hour uh he set out to
defraud the United States of America and
the citizens of our nation he used
tactics of harassment intimidation uh he
made threats he and his allies uh went
after State officials local officials
responsible for conducting elections now
we know they even went into voting
machines in order to you know determine
whether or not those voting machines had
somehow been breached when they were the
ones actually doing the breaching so
there is a a great deal already in the
public record we'll wait to see what the
indictments themselves say because
clearly this investigation has been very
thorough
um but I don't know that anybody should
be satisfied this this is a terrible
moment for our country to have uh a
former president accused of these uh
terribly uh important crimes the only
satisfaction may be that the system is
working uh that all of the efforts by
Donald Trump his allies and his enablers
to try to silence the truth to try to
undermine uh democracy uh have been
brought into the light and Justice is
being pursued and with all of these
indictments and upcoming trials Trump is
going to win so much that you're going
to get sick and tired of winning and by
winning I mean Trump is going to be
losing well that's all for me today
thanks so much for watching and feel
free to connect with me at I am Gabe
Sanchez but before I go I just want to
remind everyone that you can support
this show by signing up for my patreon
as a member you'll get Early Access
episodes a live weekend show q and A's
and discounted merch to subscribe go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez there it
is so what was that the brand new one
was that from
I am Gabe Sanchez that guy with the last
name Sanchez
that's a great what was that those get
better and better I think you know I it
the more the more I work through them I
think the better they get they aren't
they're getting better they're getting
better my friend and I I'm gonna I'm
gonna send an email and a request to add
Fuentes to get them to put you on that
chart because yeah yeah it's just so
unfair to your um your detail that this
show
that this show somehow reflects onto
that piece of content and it doesn't it
doesn't everyone stick around we're
gonna be right back with
bonehead of the week right after this
we'll be right back
mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show it's Friday
Friday Friday August 18th what happens
on Friday in the third hour of the show
It's usually the second hour today the
third hour we're almost at the top of
the third hour here we're gonna do phone
ahead of the week don't go anywhere
don't touch that tile as they say on the
radio on the radio bonehead of the week
I think I'm gonna leave it like this or
should we go like this should we go like
this should we go like this should we go
like this go whatever I'm I'm currently
I am currently hold on one sec let's go
like this look at that look at that how
does that look boom
yeah now we're getting somewhere see the
problem with this view is that the bone
of the week logo is over me so it
appears that as you're the bonehead as I
am the bonehead of the
weekly understand that it could be I'm
looking down at my I'm looking down on
my computer right now I'm uh I'm just
I'm just gonna quickly fact check Elon
Musk because he decided to be a [__]
bonehead in the last minute dude what
did he do well he decided that uh he's
gonna remove the block feature
but wait wait so you can't block someone
this is nor can someone block you that
you know what that means you know what
that meanscape cinches well he can't do
it but sure what does it mean it means
that Seb Gorka can no longer block you
I just I'm just throwing that out there
man I'm just throwing that out there I'm
not
that Elon shoulder shouldn't do this or
he can or can't do this I'm just saying
that it if that is the case if that is
the truth if the facts bear out that
that Elon Musk can do this but he can
turn off the block feature that means
that said but can no longer block the
guy with the last name Sanchez I thought
about that and it's also Jeffrey Clark
Camp lock me right and then also um
[Music]
does Rudy got you blocked Rudy no no no
no he had me blocked but he oh yeah
that's right now okay well maybe he knew
he knew maybe he knew about this new
thing where elon's gonna turn off the
block feature Rudy I mean Rudy seems to
be on top of all these things that
aren't true that he think he wants them
to be true so why not this right do you
like the new setup here I think I like
this
yeah this is nice yeah yeah this is much
better than a little square here because
we're not as well you know you can't see
us as good here yeah we're better this
one it's better this is better I set
this up I set this up I'm not gonna lie
and set this up myself this is something
that I did you know just Pat myself on
the back here uh it wasn't that hard it
wasn't that hard I've been able to do it
for a while I've just been you know lazy
lazy yeah lazy I've been yeah I was
checking my tank to see if I needed a
shower what do you want from me what do
you want from me
should we get into bone end of the week
yes yes sorry I'm just like please stop
talking about your tank go to Bone yeah
please don't please don't do that please
okay I'm quickly I'm quickly uh like I
said I'm looking down for a second here
because I'm quickly fact checking Elon
Musk real time here real time we because
because on the Tony Michaels podcast we
obviously don't want you to have
misleading information obviously we want
to get to the facts in the heart of it
that's why I have Gabe Sanchez uh at my
side as the co-host because it it really
truly would be misleading information if
he wasn't but no misleading information
here on bone of the week these three are
all boneheads and they were all three
boneheads this exact week as a matter of
fact Donald Trump Rudy Giuliani and the
my pillow Nazi Mike Lindell oh my God I
don't even know where to start but you
know what since we mentioned Rudy
Giuliani already why don't we start
their Gabe Sanchez why is Rudy what
could possibly have put Rudy Giuliani
there's a few things okay so so Rudy has
several problems is what you're saying
so Rudy uh let's see the first off he
was uh he's a a co-defendant on this
indictment there like I mentioned in the
what was that that we just played there
is a beautiful karmic irony to it all
that Rudy Giuliani is the one who used
Rico to go after the mob and other
criminals while he was the D.A
and then now he's being charged with
Rico himself so it's it's on top of that
then you go forward and you find out
that Rudy Giuliani has made several
attempts to get paid uh from Donald
Trump foreign
[Music]
because I don't know if you remember
this but there was last year two years
ago there was a there was this leak of a
quote that came out
that Rudy Giuliani was charging Donald
Trump twenty thousand dollars a day for
legal services from him and his and and
his team right so so rude Giuliani was
the former personal oh people want the
theme music
oh okay well okay let's start the theme
music then
[Music]
[Applause]
I used to play it in the front and now I
just played in the back yeah of the of
the segment but you know it happens yeah
there's a theme music so I'm trying to
find a good clip of Rudy losing his mind
on one of his shows on Newsmax uh but
I'm I'm failing to find because there's
so much dragging of Rudy on social media
there's just you have to sift through it
all right that's right you got to get
through it all
um but apparently he this is
um
he's ranting about the uh the indictment
I think that's what he's ranting about
um and here here is uh here's here's uh
he is on Newsmax but I got another one
but here it Rudy is on Newsmax here uh
so let's see what he's saying about how
he's a lawyer that that's I think his
defense here is I'm a lawyer I mean was
a lawyer or whatever let's listen [__]
is over because they are clearly now not
cases they're not even crimes this is
the first amendment
this is Free Speech it's my acting as a
lawyer
I have a right to argue for my client
maybe yeah yeah you had the right to
argue for your client that is true but
you do not have the right to
engage in a criminal Enterprise and
commit active crime with your client
that's something you can't do you can't
do that like you that's not that I don't
I mean I'm not I'm I'm no lawyer and
honestly and I know this offends a lot
of lawyers out there when I've been
saying this but the bar of lawyer has
gotten knocked down like 20 notches here
like anyone could be a [__] lawyer
anyone can be a [__] lawyer at this
point you just gotta have enough money
well yeah I mean we know that because
every person that has represented Trump
begin to question like are you actually
a lawyer or like how did you where did
you
right uh like who did you pay off for
your yeah lawyer okay but uh let's let's
continue with uh Grandpa farty
mcsharty's
um his logic here on how he gets to
Crime because he's a lawyer let's go
with that even have a right to
exaggerate for my client
I have a basis for everything I said
half of what they wrote about me is
false and they know it
so he's basically saying I can lie for
him I can exaggerate I love that
exaggerate I can lie for him because
this this idea that somehow this was all
exaggeration is [__] and the reason
why it's [__] is because he would go
out and he would lie at the Four Seasons
Landscaping press conference or the one
where he was with the the Kraken and he
was [__] out of his temples you
remember this yeah um but when he went
into actual federal court he doesn't
have the right to do that he doesn't
have the right to do that and the reason
why you know that is because when the
federal judges ask him time and time
again in those Zoom courtroom open
courtroom hearings where is your
evidence of fraud he's like oh no no
we're not claiming fraud there's no
evidence of it he's such a [__] [__]
box this guy just a [__] [__] box
what's also funny is I was reviewing the
footage of his uh remember when he
farted the clip that we played in the
what was that right he's like
he did it twice while he was in there
and there was a question that was or a
statement that was brought up by one of
the people that were on the committee in
this panel and he said Rudy Giuliani is
just here to spread misinformation
um why should we trust him he made some
claims and then Rudy Jones oh this is
defamation these are defamatory
statements he can't say this are you
going to rein him in blah blah all this
stuff and it's like oh how funny is it
that the guy that like he he held up a
banner or a binder and was like he's
like I've got one of these and 20 more
all of these affidavits you're going to
tell me that these affidavits of people
who witness things are more credible
than what you're saying up there
and it's like yeah that's that's what we
are saying right we we're we're showing
you the evidence and there is a moment
which I will feature in this upcoming
Rudy Giuliani uh what was that which is
him at the ellipse and goes if we're
wrong we're gonna look like fools or
idiots he said something like that and
he goes and he goes if who could have
guessed and if they're right
all right and if they're if they're
wrong they're gonna go to jail and I was
like oh my gosh this are you God the
projection here the prediction
your own incompetence and Criminal
activity is going to come and then you
know two year two and a half years later
here we are
well right here here we are here we are
so let's continue with what he is a
bonehead let's keep going
this should all be put off until after
the election because it is clearly a
violation of his right to run for office
and he should bring a 1983 action to
vindicate that and see if a federal
court won't take a look at the whole
history going back to their original
crime which is Russian collusion which
was a crime by the way
the same people committing it is a crime
to collude with Russia and he is right I
mean I'm you know I'm not going to go
against Rudy on that it is a crime to
probably collude to some degree with
Russia it just has Paul manafort ask
that guy who got pardoned uh for Russia
collusion but you know who am I and oh
and you know who else the guy the guy
who got sentenced and he got pardoned uh
for going to prison
um for for [__] he did in Iowa uh with
with Ron Paul oh you know what he went
to prison he's going to prison for
accepting cash foreign cash and
funneling into the Trump campaign did
you know that did you know oh my God I
wonder if Rudy I wonder if Rudy here
knows that [__] he of course knows that
[__] yeah the crime
same people who lied about Russian
collusion lied about Biden bribery lied
about the hard drive yes Republicans yes
all yes all of you are lying about the
Russia collusion that it didn't happen
you're lying about the Biden hard drive
that doesn't really [__] exist the
Biden bribes you're lying about all of
it yes you are lying about all of that
Republicans are lying go on please and
that's the same people telling the truth
Trump me Meadows
I don't know maybe maybe people get the
point by now
yeah we yeah oh baby do we do we get the
point
the how the [__] how in the [__] do you
have so much arrogance so much [__]
absolutely I don't know if it's
arrogance or it's just incompetence oh
my God are you [__] me he's like all
the people who lied about all this stuff
like yeah those are Republicans lying
but there's like all the people telling
the truth me Trump and Meadows get the
[__] out of here you couldn't you
couldn't make this [__] up but also in
that I think it's in that same interview
he he talks to Eric bowling and he says
oh uh Bonnie Willis is a dishonest
uh unprofessional lawyer she's not she's
a politician and I was like are are you
wait hold on are you really going to say
that right now you're the same guy okay
I mean amongst many situations of your
leaky hair the Four Seasons Landscaping
you know Borat 2 uh Mass singer all of
these things but on top of that you're
being sued for defamation from the guy
in the the shopping store that you
accused
hit you that's one you're being uh
you're being sued for defamation by
Dominion voting systems you're being
sued for sexual harassment by your
former employee which by the way if
anyone has not read those uh quotes that
are in that that deposition holy [__]
they're gross
um but I'm talking about where he's
talking about her tits and she's like
give those big tits yeah those are my
titties and then on top of that and then
on top of that he just admitted in on as
of July 26th because I was looking up
this last night as of July 26th he
admitted in court he conceded and said
that he made false and defamatory
statements about ruby and
um
he admitted that he made false and
defamatory statements while he was like
oh no I didn't I'm not admitting that
those were
uh those were those were false I'm
admitting that I made false statements
about them so he doesn't want to admit
that what he he admitted what he said
about them was false but he doesn't want
to admit that there was falsehoods in
the election
and the only reason he's doing that is
because Rudy Giuliani is so cast
strapped right now that he has to settle
because he doesn't want that to go to
court well he had to sell is he had to
sell his condo in New York apparently
like a six six he hasn't he hasn't sold
it yet he wants to sell it okay is that
where he's at is that where he's at and
he's because here's another here's
another where he's in this uh leather
chair and it's yeah yeah it's usually
the same I believe that's the spot that
he's at so this is for sure but this is
where he normally films all of these
weird ass rants well this is which
people if people haven't watched these
for the last two years I've been
monitoring Rudy Giuliani on YouTube and
I've been following all of his uh his
YouTube commercial
activity slippers
slippers and home safety
there's one that I feature that I don't
know if the clip You're Gonna Play has
it in there
but there is one clip that I haven't
really seen on the internet yet of Rudy
Giuliani doing a promo In This Very In
This Very segment which is the same day
that he does his interview with Eric
Bolling on Newsmax and it's [__]
disgusting
well here's I think this is him waving
around the paper or something [__]
about how he's this is earlier on in the
in the in the segment nobody's nobody's
clipped the thing that I'm talking about
yet all right here here it is what's
wrong with you Rudy Giuliani is hopping
mad over his indictment racketeering
what the hell do you know about
racketeering he railed against Georgia's
Fulton County D.A fawnee Willis in a
rambling tirade I am
the dictator there was no wrong what
kind of lawyer are you what kind of
person are you he faces what could be a
long and expensive Court battle trouble
is Giuliani is reportedly broke he's
running out of money I mean I don't know
about running out I think might be out
he's so strapped for cash he's been
forced to sell his home giuliani's
apartment in this landmark building on
Manhattan's Upper East Side was listed
for sale two weeks ago the three-bedroom
spread is described in the listing as
Splendid and the price sure is 6.5
million dollars plus there's a ten
thousand dollar monthly maintenance fee
despite all the work Giuliani did for
Trump back in 2020. he allegedly got
stiff what's wrong with you wait wait
work he did you mean you mean all the
crime he committed yeah that's the best
part about it it's all Trump's like yeah
commit crime for me I'll pay you he
commits the crime he gets it down he's
like no I'm not gonna pay you yeah but
also it's like why would it why would
Rudy Giuliani think that there was going
to be any other outcome to this
situation and here's the thing the same
time I believe it was within like a few
days of each other and I'm gonna show
this in the what was that is that Rudy
Giuliani settled he conceded he admitted
that he he made he lied he made false
and defamatory statements about ruby and
Shea Moss about their dealing he said oh
they got a thumb drive no it was a
[__] gingerman so after after two
almost three years well actually three
years three years of him lying about it
we saw the video of him making this this
statement in the Jan six hearing footage
he now comes and says you know what I
made I made false and defamatory
statements about them and the only
reason he did that and I think he owes
them each ninety thousand dollars or
collectively ninety thousand dollars I
have to double check on that decision
but the reason that Rudy Giuliani
settled that and also listed this condo
within a week of each other
is because as we found out right now
Rudy Giuliani is so [__] broke
he's so desperate for money not only did
he go down to Mar-A-Lago to beg Trump
for money to pay his legal bills it
wasn't only him it was also um
there was another lawyer who went down
there as well and they were just totally
unlucky in their uh their their well I
think I think the report was is that
Trump ended up giving like a 50 000
payment to uh to one of these document
agencies that were compiling yeah it was
for the vendor it was for the vendor so
he paid the vendor to do this because
that was the process in terms of like
here are all these documents we have to
go through electronic storage that these
law firms use and that is what was that
was what was used and so there was an oh
Costello Costello I think was the other
one I think it was that's the guy who
went and testified in front of the
Manhattan D.A yeah so Costello and then
also Giuliani went down to Mar-A-Lago
I'm almost positive discussell they went
down to Mar-A-Lago begged Trump to be
like hey you got to pay these legal
bills and the way that Rudy works when
he pays or with the way that Trump works
when he pays bills and Michael Cohen has
gone on on uh different shows and talked
about this
he won't pay
they'll be like you gotta pay so he'll
pay a little bit and then he won't pay
anything for a while and they're like
you got to pay and then he'll pay a
little bit less than what he paid before
and then he'll go even longer on not
paying that's how Donald Trump Works
he's never gonna pay the person outright
never gonna pay them up front unless
it's it's unless it's Chris case out of
Florida which was the lawyer that said I
want a three million dollar retainer
smartest move I've ever seen a lawyer
that worked with Donald Trump actually
do and actually get paid to do despite
the fact that Donald Trump did not
listen to any of the legal advice that
Chris guys gave which is hilarious so
you have you have Rudy Giuliani doing
YouTube commercials doing cameos he's
doing all sorts of other content to make
money and now he's got to sell a 6.5
million dollar condo that that he wants
to get 6.5 million I don't think he's
going to get 6.5 million dollars so
we'll see about that but it just it's
all of these things are lining up it's
special that is broke it's it's
spectacular with the ten thousands uh a
month maintenance fee is spectacular
speaking of speaking of Rudy Giuliani
Hawkins [__] slippers he sells Mike
lindell's my pillow slippers my slippers
he literally Hawks slippers on his show
from Mike Lindell and Mike Lindell just
happens to be you know what it's kind of
funny the web of bonehead that we have
on the bonehead poll this week but Mike
Lindell
he had a flop of palooza down in
Springfield Missouri big floppy [__] big
old on the Flopper we kind of we kind of
covered it yesterday but is there one of
your favorite clips that you have of
Mike Lindell that you'd like me to play
for bone of the week because I'm sure
there's like what I found there was one
hold on there was one with a drone that
had uh what what wait they had a drone
in the building yeah let me see if I can
find it what the [__] that's weird I can
find the I'm trying to find the clip but
I can I have the hold on is this here
here's this one here's this one here uh
a mic yes I got it I got it I got it I
got it okay okay fine now and I'm gonna
play this one this is at the
floppapalooza let's let's listen oh
that's sorry there's nothing to see here
we're not on the internet
we have been told this
by air
oh no that's not the one I was gonna
play here's the one I was gonna play
hello I'm sorry there's nothing to see
here we're not on the internet
we have been told this
what they're not on the internet and
then this might gets cut listen I think
I think a lot of this [__] that they do
when they're cutting mics and having
technical difficulties I think a lot of
that they're doing on purpose so they
can be like oh it's the Deep State yeah
they're gonna you know speaking
Vietnamese you know infected me
victims from the my pillow Nazi so this
is a clip
of them on stage and there's a drone
and he's going to explain and talk about
what the Drone is used for election
fraud who's this guy sitting there who's
the Santa Claus guy sitting next I don't
know that's a good that's a good
question I don't know who that guy is
but uh he's got a little campaign tie he
dude with the candy cane it looks like
Santa Claus he could be Santa who knows
maybe this is Santa and he's like I can
find out the election fraud by by
reverse engineering all the addresses
that people have on the on the good and
the the naughty and nice list do you
think Santa has the evidence at the
North I think Santa does have the
evidence because he's able to know these
are real people and I can see them in
their sleep so I know if they're real or
they're alive or dead this could be it
folks this could be why this could be
why it took so long uh to get to the
truth that Mike Lindell has been
alluding to is because Santa has been
working at his Workshop in in the North
Pole to really put together this
evidence for the American people to see
that uh once and for all that yes the
election was stolen oh
let's listen
search up why don't you show them what
we did what we did whoa whoa whoa
Santa's name is Jeff well did you hear
that street name it's a street name okay
I guess like his gang gang his gang name
right yeah okay I I didn't know I had no
idea that Santa Claus is uh street name
is Jeff but let's go let's keep going in
Florida the election crime Bureau is
proud to introduce the wmd or Wireless
monitoring device the wireless
monitoring device is a sophisticated
network connection monitoring system
designed specifically with election
security is this made up come on what
the [__] what the [__] is this if the w
m z w m d no way did they
date no way this monitoring device no
way did they name it the wmd they know a
w and D of course of course because they
wanted to be like oh man we're gonna
send in the wmd to stop this voter fraud
can anyone and then they're someone's
gonna be like well did you guys find the
wmds which is going to be even more
funny because the fact that like well
there were no wmvs in Iraq and there's
no wmds or those no voter fraud here
with the election this is not real no it
is not this is they're totally punking
Mike Lindell come here it is totally
real this is a wmd welcome to the
election crime Bureau
okay
well when I have
a picture of this show you're gonna love
this what was that
welcome back told that our election
computers are never connected to the
internet the wmd will put that to the
test by detecting and Reporting in real
time Wi-Fi connections in county and
state election offices when an online
connection is detected the election
crime Bureau Master alert system will be
quickly notified and the alerts will be
displayed on the alert web page
we now can catch them in a lie well how
would you like
I just want to point something out I
just want to point something out uh here
at your local elections there is the
internet because you need the internet
to double check and verify your identity
for people who go and vote and there is
electronic
polling stations you go in and there's a
there's an iPad tablet like here in La
they've got iPad tablet you scan your
your card you skip you have your ID they
say check your ID they look you up in
the system wait wait look you up in what
system how do they how do they connect
to the system
uh it's like a it's like a thing I don't
know it's like on the world wide web uh
it's connected so that they can because
here's the thing
no one has an isolated database okay
because you're going to have to look
people up who are not in that District
so they'll have to do a professional
ballot so they'll look you won't be like
oh you're not here actually in this
location
and then when they say oh you you can
vote here but we'll give you this spell
it and this is how we'll do it
the devices are connected to the
internet
the these the the the voting systems I
don't know if they're I mean they might
be localized to that area like on a
network there and they they record
everything in terms of each device and
they you know they were they are able to
download the data from those devices if
they're trying to prevent any sort of
hacking but I can tell you the iPads are
connected if you have those they are
connected to the internet which means
that any and that's not only that's not
the only thing
for you know if you're at a Rec Center
you're at a you're at a you're at uh
like a church or whatever it might be
like the different places that are
actually polling stations those places
have Wi-Fi okay they have the [__]
internet somewhere in an office
somewhere or in a general space so the
idea that you would fly a [__] well
here we'll wait for the Drone to make it
yeah okay let's go back to the video
I see it demoed right here in this room
[Music]
[Applause]
this is coming at you right now
everybody outside the building
[Laughter]
foreign
special delivery everybody special
delivery
[Applause]
so this is a DJI this device as it flew
into this building it just grabbed all
of your cell phones everybody in this
room every device that's on the internet
right now and let's see can you put it
up on the big screen now what this does
when this gathers information I have a
command center for this information goes
down it flashes it'll go uh um router
online just went online in in Missouri
right it goes there it comes back and
and now here's what just came in as we
came into the building here you see all
the cell phones there all the comp
computers uh we've got all these things
up there like you've seen that we pulled
off in uh that we did in Florida this is
as it goes through this filter imagine
it's election election name now we
already filtered this out we were
showing you that there's no device in
the world that does what this does I'm
telling you what we can do now if you're
in a room and you're hearing Springfield
Missouri and you're in this room and
this is an election room
beep beep beep the router just went
online this red alert goes out there he
knows that that any phone that's
connected to um uh what is it a data
Tower is online he knows that right yeah
but so here's here's the way that this
is a little bit different so so like I
said before I was like you've got your
pulling you got your machines right and
then you download the data from there
typically they're on an isolated Network
so that no one can hack it so that's how
that works right I think there was
someone even in the chat that was like
I'm a poll worker they're not connect
internet exactly they're not connect to
internet you download them locally and
then that's by professionals that's how
it's done when you go in if your polling
station has an iPad you are connected to
the internet to look up that voter in
the system okay you don't have isolated
databases on each iPad and all that
stuff and on top of that like I'll just
reiterate the fact that if you are in a
business you are going to have a Wi-Fi
router like you're going to have a
network set up somewhere so that people
can connect if you connect to your local
like just the cell tower using you know
LTE or 3G or 5G or whatever whoa whoa
easy on the vaccine stuff I know I know
I'm just saying if you happen to be a
walking walking 5G station question mark
vaccinated question mark does the wmd
does the wnd detect if they're
vaccinated too you know I was thinking
that I've seen I was thinking that same
thing I don't know how many are going to
go off if the 5G actually detects it so
if I'm on my phone right now I'm not
connected to the internet right I'm I'm
connected to a cell tower I can still
get online but what Mike Lindell is
doing he just went through and he pinged
all these phones right he's spying on
you and he just he just scraped all of
your all of your information or at least
the accessible stuff to be like here are
the phone numbers or here's the IP
address that you're connected to which
would be the cell tower whatever
here's the thing nowhere nowhere else
does any place do this yes they do it's
called the [__] Capital the capital
building is that how they is that how
they got all that data yeah that's right
so that is how so one thing the Capitol
Building because it's a federal building
can legally do that as a term of
security because they've got uh
magnetometers that they go through you
know the metal detectors they've got
constant uh detection in terms of
cameras everyone who walked into that
building with a phone is immediately
flagged and they know exactly who you
are and where you went that's why they
were able to find you if you didn't post
a photo of yourself like a dumbass at
the Capitol uh I I got some news here we
get we got a hell sparklers those
Sparkles are rating us on Twitch so I
want to welcome all the sparklers hey
this Joe we're on bone end of the week
right now we're talking about Mike
Lindell so it's right up your alley
sparklers I know I know Hal likes to
knock on Michael yeah so when my when
Mike Lindell says there's no other
system or there's no other place that
does this that's false any government
building anywhere that's secure anyone
that has to fear
for any sort of uh data breach data
security anything like that
they will have that they will monitor
your cell phones if you walk in the
building now what Michael Lindell did is
he did it and then showed it to you and
that's uh I I'm gonna go on a limb
that's not legal to do
because it depends on how they're using
it right well the other thing too do you
remember
um the last election in Arizona there
were people standing outside the polling
location and they were reporting people
walking in like they were taking down
their license plates and [__] yeah and
the courts got a order for them to get
the [__] away from the polling stations
mainly the drop boxes right because they
were like oh we gotta watch these drop
boxes we covered this [__] for weeks and
weeks and weeks oh we gotta cover we
gotta you know turn people in that are
dropping ballots and drop boxes and [__]
and they were taking people's
information which you can't intimidate
people at the election polls so imagine
this imagine you go to the lecture poll
and there's this [__] drone with
something that's called a wmd attached
to it flying over the polling location
scraping your data information as you're
walking into the bowl that's hey that's
um what do you call it that's voter
intimidation Mike yeah you [__] idiot
he's such a [__] bonehead that's why
that's why Mike Lindell not only because
of floppapalooza because they they climb
right out in the they're like look we
want to intimidate you so you don't vote
that's what we want so Mike Lindell
ended up on bonehead of the week now we
have we have some uh other uh
insurrectionists and seditionists
there's a big theme everyone everyone is
connected to this uh attempt to overturn
the 2020 election it is now you
kind of confirmed this and then uh
before but I think it's been confirmed
now that our Alpha cook
um our Alpha cook the guy who wears his
little sister's t-shirts
um Fenton the Baby Gap Thompson yes is
the co-conspirator number one now this
is on the DC case right no this is on
the Georgia case oh okay see it see it's
hard to keep track of they haven't the
only one and I haven't double checked
yet but there's the DC case the one that
everyone was curious about was I think
and I don't know if we got an answer to
that but these were the 30
co uh unindicted co-conspirators that
were listed in the Georgia case and most
of them have been identified with a
couple that weren't I mean we had the
CEO of the Cyber ninjas that was
identified as well as a data analyst we
had Tom fitton as well as other people
locally in Georgia
but yeah when it came out yeah Coke and
spear number one is Thompson of Judicial
Watch not to be confused with the actual
lawyer he's not one
um even though hey Tom it's not that
hard to be a lawyer apparently go get
your long license Go pass the bar oh
right even though it's not that hard
even Tom Fenton can't do it the
indictment refers to Trump's speech on
November 4 2020 in the indictment it
says falsely declaring victory in the
2020 presidential election and the
individual one discussed a draft of that
speech approximately four days earlier
on October 31st so they were already
drafting letters announced and declaring
that he was the winner even though they
didn't know if he was going to win
because the election hadn't uh what's it
called happened yet
um so Tom Benton is a seditionist at
best not a lawyer at the least so for
sure so Tom Benton got cucked in this uh
in this and people go back to I think so
the it dropped on the 15th or the what
was it came out Monday and I think I
tweeted out Monday night or or a Tuesday
early morning and during the show I was
like
if I was a bed man right well here's
here's how fitting is the here's your
here's your here's your tweet from
August 15th and here's the actual part
of the indictment it says on or about
the fourth day of November 2020 Donald
Jessica Trump oh excuse me John Trump
sorry and I misread that there made a
nationalized nationally televised speech
falsely declaring victory in the 2020
president's election approximately four
days earlier from that on or about
October 31st 2020 Donald Jessica Trump
drafted a draft discussed a draft speech
with unindicted code conspirator
individual one he's not named but we now
know it's it's Tom I wear my little
sister's shirts
whose identity is known to the grand
jury that falsely declared Victory and
falsely claimed voter fraud the speech
was an overt act to furtherance of the
conspiracy now here's the thing if this
is true and you said Can someone notify
Tom Benton for me uh he blocked me after
I called him out for pretending to a
lawyer sending an email to the White
House on 1031 seems the date seem they
match telling them to make a statement
that Trump won and wearing shirts that
are three sizes too small it's creepy um
here's the thing you know what this
tells me more than anything is that Tom
Fenton who claims to be a trump
supporter he's an adamant Trump
supporter online he speaks out and and
supported Trump yet he went to Georgia
and testified to the grand jury and
turned evidence on Trump that's what it
tells me that's what that tells me hey
Trump all those people around you that
are giving the really shitty advice that
they're giving you you can't trust them
they're [__] morons and they're
turning on you dummy before their own
[__] legal safety and not only that
but we have to remember that the legal
advice that Donald Trump took when it
came to withholding the documents from
the National Archives
and the FBI and continuing to lie to
them and say no no we gave you
everything we don't have anything
there's no reason I would lie to you I I
gave you everything you guys have it I
don't have anything
the person that Donald Trump listened to
was Tom Fenton the guy who's not a
lawyer he got Donald Trump in more legal
trouble by telling him no no they're
your documents you were president
and those are your documents and Donald
Trump said hey Chris guys go [__]
yourself I don't need to listen to
anyone
Jim trusty no no I don't want to listen
to you Alina have but no no Christina
Bob no no all of those people and the
rest of the list of Misfits of his legal
team he never listened to anyone and the
person he actually listened to didn't
even have a law license well and
apparently he wears makeup is this a
real picture of him that is him this is
not misleading information I want ad
Fontes to note this uh as they uh are
examining our edited photo I did not
touch this up this really is blush that
is him that is him for sure Tom Fenton
welcome to Alpha cook I don't think he's
been the alpha cook he's been on
bonehead of the week yeah he's been on
bone of the week and it could have been
for the very reason for what we just
said which was he told Donald Trump to
withhold documents and two lies yeah
that's why I think that's why he was on
uh bonehead of the week before now we
have a dishonorable mention today uh
you're gonna hear this guy's name more
and more and more and when you hear his
name make sure you say it correctly just
like I say Matt Getz that's the correct
print pronunciation at least here at the
Tony Michaels podcast but this guy's
name is Kenneth cheese bro they want a
cheeseburger yeah well we could call him
Kenna cheeseburger cheeseburger
cheeseburger I just know him as Kenneth
extra mayo cheeseburger it's true it's
true why is he the dishonorable mention
this morning well it turns out like
right before the show started it turns
out that our boy Kenny extra mayo
was that the uh at the Capitol on
January 6 and hanging out with a little
somebody that we talked about earlier in
the show wait are you telling me that
you pulled an audible at the very last
moment I did because that's how we work
here on bonehead of the week there are
moments in which the AC the alpha cuck
and the DM the dishonorable mention can
find themselves with the last minute
audible so they get replaced the old
Switcheroo well here is here's what
appears to be Mr cheeseburger uh at the
Capitol in a trump hat now the word is
is that he was he was there with Alex
Jones That's right The Alex Jones that
you're thinking of there's a lot of Alex
Jones out there but he was there
specifically with Alex Jones here's a
report um this morning that broke on CNN
because CNN broke this story that cheese
bro who is an architect this isn't just
like some [__] redneck from Texas
that decided to go the capital to
overthrow the government for his Lord
and Savior Donald Trump okay this is a
guy who is one of the architects who is
now indicted on on the architecture the
Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
the attempt to overthrow the election
this guy was on the ground at the
Capitol with Alex Jones now again I want
to clarify these facts Alex Jones is a
really good friend with Stuart Rhodes
the oath keeper he knows he knows
Enrique atario with the proud boys okay
these people are all interconnected
Stewart Rhodes used to sleep let me let
me reader it stewards used to sleep on
Alex Jones's couch oh yeah are you
listening are you listening to what I'm
saying now you Ed Fontes can say that's
misinformation or whatever but I got a
pretty good source I got a pretty good
source that says Stuart Road slept on
Alex Jones's couch for wait wait tell me
who who's that Source uh it could be his
estranged son Dakota Adams and his
exchange ex-wife Tasha Adams and they
would know that where he was staying so
uh so I got that piece of information
the other thing I want you to know is
that uh Ryder stone is really good
friends with Alex Jones he's done Alex
Jones Show all the time these two
[__] know each other like like
um you know cupcakes and icing but
here's the thing
Roger Stone is good friends with um
what's that guy's name that ran for
president 2016 lost a popular vote but
then barely won um the electorial count
ending the loss in 2020. uh drumpf no no
no Jessica Trump Donald Donald Jessica
Trump that's what it is yes wait wait
it's not Juanita no no no not Juanita
Jessica okay he he's very good friends
with Roger Stone Roger Stone it happens
that Roger Stone Roger Stone was
supposed to be protected by the proud
boys the day of January 6 after a
meeting of Stewart Rhodes and Enrique
tario who are both convicted of
seditious conspiracy meaning in a
parking garage the day before they
decided that the Oath Keepers would
protect Roger Stone that day on January
6th now nor Alex Jones nor Roger Stone's
name appears anywhere in these
indictments which I know there was
actually one one thing I want to add to
that I don't know if people know this I
don't know if you know this but
prosecutors are looking to charge
Enrique tario with a 33 year prison
sentence yes for seditious conspiracy
yeah
multiple people but yeah 33 years so
Enrique atario the guy who was supposed
to not be in DC on January he wasn't
there he wasn't there on January the guy
who wasn't even on the ground that the
capitol is going to get 30 well pots of
the prosecutors asking for 33 [__]
years in a federal prison that's a lot
of [__] time but this guy Kenneth
chisborough
cheeseburger here was with Alex Jones on
the grounds at the Capitol again this
guy is not some [__] just any old
weirdo
this is the game
um we need a big chart with all these
connections it's not really that hard
Alex Jones and Roger Stone uh they love
to [__] with Donald Trump they love that
and they're they're proud boys and Oath
Keepers and they all committed seditious
conspiracy and cheese burrow was with
him who plan who helped plan the state
elector you don't really need it it's
almost like this like pyramid that's
going on right and at the very top it's
almost like
um it's almost like in Georgia they're
they're going after the very same way
for this group like there's it's almost
like it's an Enterprise kind of thing
you know like
Syndicate maybe yeah you know you go at
the top you know Illuminati uh you go at
the top and you've got Donald Trump and
then you trickle down to all these
people the middlemen and the bottom
people right that did all these things
for them so he's the top there the
bottom I don't I can't buy look I don't
think he's a bottom
it's definitely a bottom he's definitely
on the bottom definitely bottom but in
terms of the position of the hierarchy
on this triangle this pyramid it's
Donald Trump at the top that's not to
say he's the top of normal life he's
definitely a bottom he's a little [__]
I'm not saying that bottom is [__] I'm
just saying Donald Trump is a [__] ass
[__] and I didn't say those words but
Chrissy Teigen did yeah she did she
posted he got mad uh it's a it's a
legitimate question when you're asking
who's pitching who's catching but here
is here is the report this morning about
Cheeseburger on CNN the new exclusive
reporting this morning about pro-trump
lawyer Kenneth oh and where he was
during the Insurrection on January 6 at
the U.S Capitol he was the alleged
architect behind the plan to submit a
fraudulent slate of electors after Trump
lost a 2020 race he was also among 19
people including Trump indicted this
week on racketeering and other charges
in Georgia's election subversion case
our calling in CNN senior crime and
Justice correspondents from Oak porcupez
joins us with his exclusive reporting
what do we need to know yeah so this is
a significant new information that was
uncovered by our investigative team here
at CNN and it shows that he was at the
Capitol on the capitol grounds just
outside the doors of the Capitol
surrounded by the mob of protesters also
following around the leading voice of
the stop the steel movement conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones and the big question
is what was he doing there
he is one of the electrical conspirators
in two cases against Donald Trump for
2020 election interference now for the
first time CNN has identified Kenneth
chespro outside the capitol on January 6
shortly before a mob stormed the east
side of the building he followed
right-wing conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones for about an hour chess bro is the
alleged architect of a plot to use fake
electors to stop the certification of
Joe Biden's win this week he was
indicted along with Trump and 17 others
in Georgia he's also been identified as
an unindicted co-conspirator in the
federal case against the former
president CNN projects Joseph R Biden Jr
is elected the 46th president of the
United States in the days after the
November 2020 election chesborough wrote
a memo to a lawyer for Donald Trump it's
among the earliest known documents
outlining the legal strategy Trump would
allegedly try to use his memo focuses on
January 6 as the hard deadline with
ultimate significance to determine the
validity of electoral votes emails
obtained by the January 6 committee
showed chesborough later suggesting to
the Trump campaign that the fear of
quote wild Chaos on that day could
provoke the Supreme Court to take action
go to the White House at the same time
Alex Jones was helping pay for and plan
the January 6 rally urging his massive
audience to gather in Washington D.C the
night before Trump's rally Jones would
warn of a coming battle this will be
their Waterloo this will be their
destruction we fight
we fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore when the January 6
committee asked if chesborough was in
Washington the first week of January
chess bro pleaded the fifth
absolutely
but there is no question he was there
CNN has analyzed publicly available
photos and videos from that day which
show his movements in the hours before
the Insurrection he was with Alex Jones
and his Entourage a short distance from
the capitol chesbro is here wearing a
red Trump 2020 hat as lawmakers prepared
to certify the results of the election
inside the building Chester follows Alex
Jones and a crowd of protesters as they
walk towards the capitol chesbro has his
phone out seemingly recording Jones's
every move
[Music]
as Jones was leading a crowd to the east
side of the Capitol the west side was
breached and rioters poured in so there
you go there's a cheeseburgers uh
contributions we are peaceful let's not
give the police let's not fight the
police and give them what they want oh
yeah okay nobody heard that no no you
know what you know what you know what
happened Alex Jones knew he was in
trouble Alex Jones Alex Jones he's like
oh this got really intense really quick
it's crazy as he sounds Alex Jones is
actually a really smart [__] the
problem is is the guy does it drinks way
too much alcohol yeah way too much
alcohol the guy's a [__] drunk and
the other thing too is it's all
entertainment to him he's it's just a
big [__] character that Alex Jones
plays but Alex Jones knew the danger
there on the capitol that day he was
like oh [__] they really did what I
wanted them to do because Alex Jones is
all [__] talk with the gay frogs and
the and someone is Alex Jones turns
frogs gay oh he turns Frog's gate well
that man that could be could be very
true I don't know I mean if a frog
looked at Alex Jones like well you know
maybe maybe just maybe I'm gay
um but at for the dishonorable mention
today we have Kenneth the cheeseburger
we're on our list and for for the bone
net of the week dishonorable mention now
we go to the winner which we all know
who the wiener is this week in bone of
the weiner oh my God it was not even
close not even [__] close
now the reason why I had uh the wiener
here Donald Jessica Trump on uh my radar
for bonehead of the week was that
obviously
um what was the thing that happened this
week was there something to happen
is there something that happened I don't
know was there news was there oh that's
right there was another indictment yeah
but you know the reason why I mean fifth
time's the charm right well sixth
seventh eighth hell we might get a 10th
indictment who knows but here's the
thing is that the reason why I wanted
him on the bonehead of the week last
night
and when you sent over the list because
I was at the concert and they were they
were playing loud music right right and
and you sent me the list I'm like yeah
you decide what you want I just hope and
Donald Trump makes it on there right
the reason why I wanted him on there is
because he [__] chickened out on the
debates and now that he chickened out on
money on his press conference because he
was gonna be like oh yeah all that
evidence that Mike Lindell is going to
come up with this weekend at the
floppapalooza in Springfield Missouri
I'm gonna go roll that out on Monday and
it's gonna exonerate me and Mike
lindell's like um we don't have any
evidence this is he's like did you guys
see that drone though
did you see that wmd that wmd did you
see that wireless monitoring device the
the weapon of mass destruction which by
the way I okay so the device that's in
there it's in a it's in a water water
sealed uh
container okay
uh that I've worked with previously at
other companies where I've done uh
electronics and it's just something you
can buy off online whatever and then
you've got a little whatever this
monitoring device is that's capturing
which is probably some hacked together
thing it might it could be an official
thing but I I don't know who's who's
selling it the only people I could
honestly see it is like
there are like spy gadgetry that you can
buy online you know it's like don't use
it to spy on other people but if you
want to use it to like monitor whatever
you could use it that's what I imagine
is happening then there's a relay and
the relay goes to a cell tower and the
cell tower comes back to the network and
the network brings it down to whatever
they're displaying on their computer
right
or it goes them and it records them on
on their database they're like there's
their server and and then displays it on
on the uh the wmd website that they have
so
the thing about that is it's a a DJI
which is a which here we go
Tony was there um
was there a country that these
Republicans are really afraid of getting
hold of certain voter information
well I remember there's a Italy there's
space lasers there's Hugo Chavez and
there's a China thing yeah China so the
here we go
we don't want vagina voting information
give to China are voting our voting
machines so tell me tell me about this
the Drone I can tell you as someone who
owns one the Drone that they flew into
this little made
DJI is a Chinese company oh [__] and it
already people already have fear they're
like oh yeah DJI and it is a great
device like as a drone like phone it's
great to capture stuff and a lot of
people like oh no why are we doing that
because we don't know if China is
capturing yeah information there might
be a device inside the device that we
don't know about that's sending that's
sending information back yeah it's
mapping it's it's it's using hobbyists
and professionals to map out a country
and things around there for them so
so Mike Lindell just sent in a Chinese
manufactured drone
with a captured device with a device to
capture different phone signals right
and and uh and flew it in wait are you
saying are you saying that Mike Lindell
had a better Chinese spy device than
this Chinese spy balloon is that what
you're saying yes it feels like that's
what you're saying it's possible so that
is what happened the the beauty of him
sending in a wireless monitoring device
is the fact that he put it on top of a
Chinese manufactured drone that people
already have fears of capturing and
monitoring data in our country and
others so you can't make this stuff up
this is how dumb these Republicans are
they're like oh we got you right now but
we're gonna tell you exactly how we're
gonna do it we're gonna capture your
data your cell phone data without your
knowledge without your permission as a
private entity not a government who's
trying to Monitor and secure under the
page then we're gonna make sure it goes
back to China and then we're gonna send
it back to China well speaking of making
[__] up you got to listen to this for
the bonehead of the week this is one of
the I listen I I am becoming more and
more in love with the fact that Donald
Trump really believes it it is apparent
that he believes he's going to talk his
way out of these indictments like he's
talked his way out of everything else in
his life he is just for sure thinking
that he's gonna talk his way out of this
and I'm in love with this I mean you
mean talk his way into it well whatever
I'm talking about from his perspective
see if you can make sense of any of
these words that he uses in the order
that he uses them let's let's listen
it's a Witch Hunt is just a continuation
of which hunt they want to silence in
you if they want to silence you and they
mean silence they are uh I think they're
sick people I think they are people that
uh have no idea how the world works and
they have no idea the anger they cause
you know we have a tremendous group of
people in this country and I'm not just
talking talking about Republicans we
have them on both sides and we have a
lot of them and when they watch us Witch
Hunt this disgusting situation where
they do it for publicity where they do
fundraisers based on you know she yeah
and they're all bad but in her case
because I have four of them now if you
look I mean you do oh it is possible a
couple of months uh and frankly it
discredits everything it does discredit
everything you've done sense that
they're uh there's no basis for them
it's a Witch Hunt oh my God I can't I
honestly I can't tell you how [__]
excited I am at the prospect that
Georgia will be televised and that this
[__] bonehead the bonehead of the
week this week this [__] bonehead it
is possible that he would be like nope
I'm taking the stand I'm taking the
stand I'm gonna exonerate myself I'm
gonna talk my way out of this I'm like
hey man nothing better than that let's
do that [__] because let me tell you in
front of a jury of his peers in Georgia
if he talks nonsense like that they're
gonna be like what the [__] you're
guilty as [__] man so I can't wait what
was the what was the guy's name that
killed his [__] wife and his son and
uh it was a big try Alec Alex Murdoch
was that his name oh no no yay it was
Alex
there's a lot of documentaries and that
guy like I watched that morning when the
judge was trying to talk that guy out of
not getting on the stand the judge is
like are you sure he spent like 30
minutes telling this guy you do not want
to do this Alex Murdoch if you do this
if you get on this stand you will be
found guilty like there's a reason there
is a reason why when you are when you
have a uh uh when you go to court and
there's something very serious like that
like murder or you know in this case
there's like oh you were the head of
this enter this [__] Enterprise uh
and under RICO charge right there's a
reason why you don't want to put that
person up because look you're going to
hurt your case if you speak that's why
so many people in various cases that are
like heavy hitting cases they're like
please well do not hurt your reputation
or your case by going up there no no no
no there's only one person that can get
me out of this I got it it's me well the
only person that got me into it even
even Alec Murdoch that morning because I
watched that hearing that's the only
hearing I watched live with this Murdoch
thing that's the only thing I really
watch live I watch some documentaries I
watch some other footage but that
hearing was so [__] great because
even his attorneys the judges are the
judges like did you advise against him
they're like yes we do not want him to
do this his attorney is like please talk
him out of this he's totally guilty
and they're like no we do not want him
to do this and the judge is like but of
course the attorneys can't force the
defendant not to speak they had the
right to speak at their trial they had
the right to testify on the stand and so
he did and um Alec Murdoch is in [__]
prison right now because he didn't
listen to the advice of his lawyers so
in that celebration of that I don't know
that's why I'm excited that this guy
really thinks he's going to talk his way
out of this with his nonsense but listen
to this [__] deranged ass
hostage video and see if you know we
haven't watched one of these in a while
we used to watch these and we used to
give a Liz Harrington which I think
she's a viewer of the show too maybe
Fontes actually she watches because she
definitely takes our feedback and gets
yes she did she did so when we we would
watch these videos when he first started
doing them we would we would you know
give them critiques and not just
political critiques but we'd also like
the lighting and the editing and that
sort of [__]
um but here's this one and we haven't
played one in a while because they're so
[__] wild but this one man this one's
significant and he's on the bone of the
week so I figured I'd play let's let's
watch this one full subpoena power
because of the
freedom of speech sham indictment by
crooked Joe Biden deranged Jack Smith
and the doj
it has just been reported that the
unselect January 6 committee they are
unselected indeed
okay first off all right
here's the thing this guy totally stands
in front of the mirror and does this
[__] you know that right yeah 100 he's
standing in front of a mirror he's
always looking at himself he's like and
he's like and he's and he's like oh
that's a unselect oh that's really good
that's really good that really Nails him
or some [__] but the the craziest part
is what he says next the just the
absolute [__] lies that are
absolutely uh checkable it's insanity
but let's listen
a political hacks and thugs has
illegally destroyed all of their records
and their documents so they took all of
their records all of their documents
they reported it
tried to get me indicted and probably
did they did they tried to get me
indicted and probably dude you've got
four invitations four indictments two of
them are specifically related to the
documents and oh my God one of them
specifically related to the documents
two of them are specifically related to
trying to overturn the election three of
them are specifically related to the the
2020 January 6th overturning of the
transition of the power and one of them
is the Manhattan DA's case right so it's
probably probably one probably dude they
got you on four man definitely
definitely
well at five including the superseding
that's true that's not even saying there
might not be an additional Superstar oh
there's gonna be tons of SuperSonic
indictments tons of Super Scene
indictments here's the other thing too
is he is totally telling on himself that
he deleted and destroyed something yeah
because he's like they illegally deleted
and destroyed no they didn't it's all on
the [__] website still yeah what are
you talking about man he's like I
thought we deleted those DMS and it's
like no man you there's a record of that
on Twitter no right right well see he
thinks if he you think that's what
happened well that's what I said I think
it was last week when I said I think
what Donald Trump did is he printed out
the DMS that he had with people
and then thought that if you took it if
he downloaded that's his definition if I
download the messages by printing them
oh I took them off the computer and now
I have them on physical paper and then
he shredded them he's like now I'm
deleting them and then from there he
either tried to eat them or he tried to
flush them I would say eat them [__] him
then flush them as I say that he could
have figured whatever method possible
but I think that's what happened here's
the crazy part is this guy if if it's
true he deleted those DMS from Twitter
what he doesn't know is Twitter still
has those DMs
they still have them and Jack Smith went
and got them that's why Twitter and you
know who fought
to make sure that he didn't get them uh
Elon yeah
seems kind of it's almost kind of weird
if you look at the Timeline Elon showed
up to the Capitol and that was uh uh
with
Uh Kevin McCarthy yeah and then all of a
sudden and then he's like I also met
with Hakeem Jeffries and it's like
hakeem's like no we didn't you I saw you
like in the hallway
so let me ask do you think that Donald
Trump and Kevin McCarthy were dming on
Twitter
I think they were well not at that
moment but I think they were dming
before that right I think there's a lot
of stuff I mean between kellyanne Conway
uh Kaylee mcinanny Mark Meadows uh I
think any of these people he was dming
with them not only on his personal
account but also on the presidential
account hmm and I think I think he
thought I think he thought that if he
deleted them they were gone for good
right when you delete a message on
Twitter and a DM you're just delete it
for yourself
is this they definitely got it they
still have it right that's crazy well
let's let's see what else he projects
here at the end and then he destroyed
everything now this is Unthinkable and
the fake political indictment against me
must be immediately withdrawn the system
is
no it's not the presidential election of
2020 and we have plenty of
we were a nation in decline if you were
going to take control and power and and
we we did turn around so thank you uh
for being the bonehead because you can
guarantee that Donald Trump if given a
second term would try to go and say well
hey guys why are we limited to two terms
why why can't we get more than two okay
three four five how many can I get let
me give you a little insight Donald
Trump and his cronies I would imagine
not only are they indicted currently for
for election interference and fraud and
the election
in 2020 my guess is when he is the
nominee
and this election does happen in 2024 I
would almost bet a lot of [__] money
and I'm not a betting guy but I've
almost bet a lot of [__] money that
they're gonna get charged people are
going to be charged and go to prison for
election interference and election fraud
in 2024 because right now they I almost
bet they are planning on how they are
gonna [__] interfere in this election
and they're trying to figure out a way
that because they know he's not going to
win they know he's not going to win so
they're trying to figure out a way other
than the stupid ass way that they
already indicted for that's what that's
what is gonna and one thing that mad Mac
brings up that we should not forget is
the fact that the Secret Service okay
Secret Service started deleting texts on
January 5th and January 6th but every
other day was totally fine why were they
deleting texts so when Donald Trump goes
they deleted evidence remember this is
Donald Trump trying to position himself
to say okay look there was evidence that
was deleted but I wasn't the one that
deleted it it was everyone else it was
the Jan six sham Committee hearing or
the the Sham committee it was the
unselect it was this it was that it was
Jack Smith there was these other people
blah blah he's going to try to find a
way to to blame and scapegoat someone
else for doing it so I just want people
to remember that what we're talking
about right now Donald Trump's saying
that oh hey look uh they deleted the the
data they deleted the evidence no that
is Donald Trump admitting to him trying
to delete the evidence
so that it's already out there so people
aren't uh like surprised at the fact
that evidence was deleted he's trying to
now say it wasn't me it was them right
well I I want to point out one more
thing of why Donald Trump probably feels
boneheaded this week
um this probably makes him feel
bone-headed because he selected
hand-picked Bill Barr to protect him as
the Attorney General from the from the
Russia collusion Mueller report like
that was the whole reason why he picked
the bar and then Bill Barr wouldn't
commit crime for Trump like Bill Barr
went right up to the line of federal
crime and Donald Trump's like just
commit federal crime in me and Bill
Barr's like no
um and he's been on Fox News saying as
much and this scumbag Donald Trump
picked this scumbag to be his personal
scumbag but he didn't and I bet Donald
Trump feels really boneheaded for for
picking this guy because one thing he
didn't count on with Bill Barr is Bill
Barr would not commit federal crime for
him for for Donald Trump that is he
would go right up to the line but he
wouldn't commit federal crime for him
but listen to these couple clips from
Foxy's this is man this is gold let's
listen then in the case of the one that
you or you could be that is Jack Smith's
trying to get he wants to get going uh
you know in January I mean right before
the Iowa caucuses I mean should they be
weighing the timing of either super
Tuesday in the case of the Georgia one
or the Iowa caucuses in the case of Jack
Smith's on what
well I mean to some degree they might
accommodate you know a few days here and
there but I don't think that that should
govern the the schedule for pursuing
these cases
uh you know you don't get immunity for
two years in the run-up to an election
uh just by saying hey I'm a candidate
you can't draw me these investigations
have been going on for a while everyone
knew about them even before he even
before he announced his candidacy so uh
if there's a chance to get it resolved
before the election it should be because
the American people should know these
are crimes that involve or potential
crimes involve moral turpitude
only crimes I was there he wanted to
commit them they're definitely [__]
crimes this is what he wanted to do Bill
Barr is
I just want to clarify and reiterate
this bill Barr's a [__] piece of [__]
and the idea that he's coming I mean in
the last year or so he's come around to
be like oh he can't do those things
that's not within his purview he can't
say those things he couldn't do those
things that was illegal this and that
whatever
Bill Barr is a piece of [__] everything
he did with the mother report to helping
Donald Trump to being there until the
very nearly the very end before he left
I mean I think he saw the right and the
wall was like I gotta get the [__] out
of here right before I because I know
someone's going to [__] jail
and someone else's gonna take over well
here's for sure the people who try to
take over were like yeah we could do
those things because Donald Trump said
we could do those things and then that's
where you get [__] Jeffrey Clark it's
right no pants man well here here is
Bill Barr describing that exact
situation on Fox news with Neil Cavuto
here it is and uh I also didn't like the
way he was uh spouting the big lie I
thought that was irresponsible but he
took it much further than even I
expected or anyone expected and during
this time listen to this is being told
by lawyers in the White House that if he
kept on going doing this he would spend
the rest of his life tangling with the
criminal justice process and that's
exactly what's happened he shouldn't be
surprised and no one else should be
surprised well the fact that bill Barr
told that to him directly that's what I
believe billboard is projecting what he
said to Donald Trump
told Donald Trump right he'll be Tangled
yeah I told him I told him I'm not going
to prison for you you dumb [__]
just do it and then he was like here's
my letter of resignation right right I
love you so much here's my letter of
resignation it's been great working for
you and I'm we'll be inside it was not
so Donald Trump uh our winner of
bonehead of the week for so many [__]
reasons that I can't even count it'll
continue to be the bonehead of the
century
let's give him his dude
[Music]
[Applause]
oh Donald Jessica Trump you are the bone
end of the week once again eventually
you know we have to take Marjorie Taylor
green off any bonehead Polk because she
always won eventually we're gonna take
that [__] off I don't know when
it's gonna be but we've got a long ways
to go for him to be a bonehead so I
don't know I don't know there's a lot
more opportunities for him to be a boner
oh [__] yes but [__] yes I don't know I
don't know how we're gonna do I don't
know how we're gonna do that everyone
stick around after the music we got a
few announcements right after this has
been burned into the week foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
get a newspaper tell you who won the
election
Oh Lordy that's uh thanks for joining us
John kid Senator John Kennedy great to
be here I've been here all week this is
great I love this show I gotta say the
Tony Michaels podcast was Tony
Michaelson Gabe saying tears they got
some of the best commentary out there
even though Anne fine test says it's in
the lower left with misleading left
laning misinformation yes it's not
it's not at all have fun task can go
suck on a popsicle in the basement by
the Sailor
ah [__] them [__] em [__] em don't miss
this weekend do not miss if you're if
you're uh if you're low on uh Gabe
Sanchez the guy with the last name
Sanchez Sanchez if you're low on Gabe
Sanchez you'll make sure to go to his
patreon page I know you you got events
this weekend what are you doing this
weekend over on your patreon page boom
all right so we got I'm gonna have a
what was that coming out about Rudy
Giuliani on weekends like we normally do
we have a weekend Roundup where we go
through all the crazy [__] that
happened in the week prior sometimes we
go down a rabbit hole and we end up
figuring out some new what was that word
that we're gonna do like there's
actually another one I'm gonna do about
Donald Trump there's a lawsuit that
Donald Trump is being sued he's going to
court in 2024. Donald Trump being sued
come on I know it's crazy it's crazy but
actually on it was a couple weeks ago we
were on one and we uh we ended up doing
a deep dive into one of the latest
developments that's been under the radar
and it's going to be coming out I just
wanted to wait for I didn't I wanted
them for the dust to settle a little bit
on this fourth slash fifth indictment
that Donald Trump got so I wanted to uh
yeah anyway on the weekends come to the
show we hang out on Sundays
um check out the patreon different tiers
and you get different perks you actually
get some merch included a mug a t-shirt
a sweater boom so go to patreon.com I am
Gabe Sanchez when you're over there
check out my patreon page we're gonna
have the Sunday rant like we always do
on Sundays here's the thing we're gonna
do a new event it's gonna be cool
everyone's gonna be welcome patreon
members are going to be able to be on
screen with me we're gonna do special
karaoke with this Discord Discord is
hopping over there so we're gonna take
advantage of it where the chat party
never stops we're gonna do some karaoke
events every single month and patreon
members get exclusive access you guys
can appear on screen with me ask me
questions talk to me during these carry
events just go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels I'm gonna give you details this
Sunday on that so if you want to get
more details go there go there also
don't forget the venmo chats I got one
for you there's a venmo chat from from
Jennifer B
says I too am
excuse me the child of a mom who
despises Republicans I was talking
earlier about how my my mother despises
Republicans she despises them so thank
you Jennifer for your venmo chat we
appreciate the support here if you guys
want to send a bitmo chat the links down
below or let you know what you know what
let me just put it in the chat here if
you guys want to send a video chat boom
and what we do we'll bring it up on the
comments uh on screen uh during the show
so you guys uh get some love there so go
to go give us a venmo chat if you want
to talk to us they're from venmo thank
you very much Jennifer also also don't
forget to subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast right here on YouTube it's free
3.99 hit the like button on your way out
also you can watch us on Twitch thanks
for Hal Sparks and all the sparklers for
showing up for a raid today on Twitch
twitch.tv Tony Michaels you can also
watch on Facebook live every single
weekday at the Tony Michaels Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central
nine Pacific and don't forget to
download the audio version on Apple
Spotify and Google when I get my act
together and get it up there in the
afternoon we're gonna do we're gonna do
a a 10 a 10 minute tip for democracy
this afternoon so be watching if your
patreon member watch for the 10 minute
tip this afternoon we're gonna do one I
promise it's gonna be 10 minutes long
we're gonna do it on a new resource that
the mighty Librarians put together over
on the Discord people can given ideas
for the Roundtable democracy but not
only that they've been giving resources
like these are internet [__] out there
looking for the resources but there's no
Collective place so mighty librarian is
trying to make a nice list so everyone
can see go see all these things the
videos the resources and she's going to
show us that and the 10-minute tip this
afternoon so stay tuned on patreon
patreon.com the Tony Michaels also visit
Gabe's patreon patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez for all the extras don't miss it
you're not going to want to miss out
and we'll see you on Monday
we'll see on Monday same time same place
what do you say [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon